TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WELCOME BACK DUE TO THE
ONGOING PROBE NINETEEN
RESTRICTIONS WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTURBED DISTANCING
IN THE HEARING BERMAN
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL THERE
WERE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WALK
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON MASKS ARE REQUIRED
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. ROOM ONE
TWENTY FIVE OF THE CAPITAL AND
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON IN THE
HEARING ROOM AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OR USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE. THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWENTY FOUR.
TO SIXTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN. FOR
EACH BILL BEING DISCUSSED TODAY
THERE WILL BE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION TO PROVIDE TWO
MINUTES EACH OF COMMENTARY.
THOSE WITNESSES HAD TO HAVE
NOTIFIED US AHEAD OF TIME OF
THEIR DESIRE TO TESTIMONY TO
GIVE TESTIMONY. FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES CALLING INTO THE
PHONE LINE WILL BE PLACED IN A
QUEUE UNTIL YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE
MUTE YOUR DEVICE INTEREST DUES
SOUND DISTORTIONS. SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WILL BE BLENDED ON
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE BE BRIEF
AND LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS ONLY TO
YOUR NAME ANY ORGANIZATION
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
AND THAT IS ALL WE WILL NOT
ACCEPT TESTIMONY AT THAT POINT.
IF YOU. DO YOU WISH TO PROVIDE
FURTHER TESTIMONY YOU CAN
PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH A THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY THREE AND MY STAFF
WILL TRY TO HELP YOU. FINALLY
THE ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCE
UNFORTUNATELY A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO THE COMEDIAN FOR
PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE
THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK AND REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON. TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING
LONGER THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED
OF. DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING OR BILL AND OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACCESS. TO ADDRESS
ANY DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I WILL
TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS. IF IT
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARN THEM THAT
CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD OF THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED AND THE
NATURE OF THE DESTRUCTIVE
CONDUCT I NAY TEMPLE EARLY
RECESSED THE HEARING. IF THE
PRODUCT DOES NOT STOP I WILL
REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SERGEANTS AND EXCLUDING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN OUR HEARING NOW WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE GOING TO
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. WE
HAVE THE FOLLOWING MEASURES ON
CONSENT AB SIX TWENTY NINE SB
SIX SIXTY. AB EIGHT OH SEVEN.
AB THREE FORTY NINE AB THIRTEEN
AT SEVENTY FOUR. ACR FIFTY TWO
ACR SIXTY SEVEN. AB EIGHT
ELEVEN AB SEVEN FORTY FIVE. AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AB
FIFTEEN. TWENTY FOUR. TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MORE
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY NAMING
RESOLUTIONS FOR MEN WHICH MEANS
THAT WE HAVE REACHED MY LIMIT
ON MALE HIGHWAY NAMES UNTIL A
HIGHWAY NAMED FOR A WOMAN IS
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE. THE
WILL WAIT TO HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT FILE UNTIL WE HAVE
A QUORUM. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
NOW. THROUGH OUR OTHER BILLS WE
HAVE NINE BILLS TO DISCUSS
TODAY WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY
FIVE FIVE BONTA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS. WITH THAT I WILL
INVITE IS WICKS TO PROCEED
WHENEVER HE'S READY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND ALL THE MEMBERS
WHO ARE HERE. I WOULD LIKE 2%
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA TODAY
WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE THE BAY
AREA TOLL AUTHORITY. IN
CONSULTATION WITH CALTRANS TO
ESTABLISH TRANSIT ONLY TRAFFIC
LANES ON THE BAY BRIDGE CORNER
DURING PEAK HOURS. MR BONTA HAS
ASKED AND I HAVE ACCEPTED TO BE
THE LEAD AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
MIGHT OF HIS RECENT DESIGNATION
AS ATTORNEY GENERAL. GOING TO
GROWING TRAFFIC CONGESTION AND
IS MAKING BUS RIDERSHIP SLOWER
AND LESS RELIABLE IN THE AY
AREA. THE CIRCUMSTANCES
EXACERBATE INEQUALITIES BY
REDUCING TRANSIT RELIABILITY
FOR THOSE WHO DEPEND ON BUSES
AND FORCE OTHERS INTO HIGH COST
CAR COMMUTES. TRANSIT
RELIABILITY. CHALLENGES IN THE
BAY AREA QUARTER PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED WORKERS WHO HAVE FIXED
AND FLEXIBLE WORK HOURS. WHO
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY LOWER
INCOME BLACK AND LATINO
WORKERS. IF THE BUSES TWENTY
MINUTES LATE EVERY COUPLE WEEKS
THESE WORKERS USUALLY TWENTY
MINUTES EARLY EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THIS IS AN EQUITABLE AND
EFFICIENT AND FLEXIBLE. EIGHTY
FOUR FIFTY FIVE USES THE TERM
TRANSIT ONLY LANE HOWEVER THE
BILL PERMITS A HIGH OCCUPANCY
VEHICLES HOV. TO USE THE
TRANSLATE AS LONG AS EACH OF
YOUR POLICIES ARE ESTABLISHED
IN A MANNER THAT SUPPORTS BUS
SPEED AND RELIABILITY TARGETS.
IMPROVING THE PERFORMANCE OF
TRANSIT BUSES ON THE BAY BRIDGE
QUARTER WILL. LOWER GREENHOUSE
GASES DEVELOP MORE EFFICIENT
AND AFFORDABLE TRANSIT SERVICE
AND PROMOTE INDEPENDENCE AND
SELF SUSTAINABILITY FOR THOSE
WHO RELY HEAVILY ON TRANSIT
BUSES. MORE BROADLY EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY FIVE WOULD INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO CAN TRAVEL
ACROSS THE BRIDGE WHICH IS
IMPORTANT FOR. AN EQUITABLE
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOUSANDS OF AREA RESIDENTS AND
FURTHER SUPPORTS. THE ECONOMIC
HEALTH AND SUSTAINABILITY
CALIFORNIA. WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
NICK TO SUFFER WITH SPURS CHIEF
POLICY. AN MTC B. A. T. VICE
CHAIR. AND ALIZE ORTIZ AC
TRANSIT BOARD PRESIDENT. YOU
ARE THE WITNESSES OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY OR THE ON PHONE. I
BELIEVE THEY'RE ON THE PHONE
OKAY OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR THE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB.
FOUR FIFTY FIVE. HELLO MAKE TO
SUPPORT THEIR YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY DIRECTOR GUIDO HOW
I'LL GET BACK TO BACK OKAY
THANK YOU THAT COULD. BOB THANK
YOU JACK COMMITTEE STUFF AND-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN PARTICULAR
THANKS THE TICKET THANKS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS THE
TAKING UP OF THE LEAD FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE MY NAME IS
NICK JUST STUCK WITH ON THE
CHIEF OF POLICY FOR SPA START
THIS- SPONSOR A BILL AB FOUR
FIFTY FIVE AND FOR THOSE WHO
WANT COMMITTEE WITH SPA WE ARE
A HUNDRED YEAR OLD THINK TANK
THAT WORKS ON TRANSPORTATION
HELPING LEAD YOU SUSTAINABILITY
GOOD GOVERNMENT AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE. I ALSO SERVE AS THE
VICE CHAIR TWENTY AND THE BAY
AREA TOLL AUTHORITY THE AGENCY
THAT ON THE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING. TRANSIT PRIORITY
ON THE BAY BRIDGE. THIS BILL
SUPPORTS OUR REGION DEPUTY
DEPLOY. PAAS TO IMPROVE TRAVEL
ABOUT THE BONTA CHUCKLE. AND
OTHER VERY HIGH- OCCUPANCY. IN
IT HIGH CAN. AND ECONOMICALLY
BY CORE. THIS IS NOT. NOT ONLY
TO BE PEOPLE MORE. BUT TO
CREATE ROOTS IN TRYING SOLUTION
IN A CORRIDOR THAT HAS BEEN
YEARS RELIED ON SAUDI PACKED
PART BECAUSE RUNNING SO CLOSE
TOGETHER. THAT EVEN A MINOR
GLITCH CAUSES MAJOR. DELAYS
ACROSS THE NETWORK. TRANSIT
THIS CORRIDOR IS EXCEPTIONAL.
THREE PANDEMIC NEARLY 75% OF
THE WEST BOUND PEAK HOUR
TRAVELERS USE TRANSIT MOST
TAKING PART. ON THE BRIDGE
ITSELF ABOUT ONE FIFTH OF WHAT
COUNTY CALTRANS LIST USED
PUBLIC BOXES. WITH MANY MORE
AND PRIVATE SHUTTLES SAMPLES IN
VERY HIGH OCCUPANCY VEHICLES.
IT'S COVERED- OFFICE
EXCEPTIONAL GROWTH POTENTIAL TO
BUS TRAVEL. THE STATE INVESTED
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
A NEW MULTIBILLION DOLLAR STATE
OF THE ART TRANSLATE TRANSIT
CENTER IN THE HEART OF SOUTH
FRANCISCO'S TOP CENTER.
OFFERING DIRECT POSSIBLY RAMPS
TO THE BRIDGE AND CAPACITY TO
SEVEN HUNDRED BOXES OUR- WE
NEED TO LEVERAGE THIS
INVESTMENT AND ITS UNIQUE BOX
ACCESS IN ORDER TO CREATE MORE
CONVENIENT AND RELIABLE TRANSIT
OPTIONS. CHANGING TRAVEL
PATTERNS IN THE PANDEMIC. ABOUT
MEETING CRINGE BUT NEED ACTION.
COVERED EVEN BEFORE MOST OF WE-
OLD DOCTOR OF THREE STOCK IS
OFF BE A CAN ON THE- CREATING
LESS RELIABLE. THE BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. CONDITION WILL GO TO
QUICKLY MORE ARE. AB FORTY FIVE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE OUR
EXISTING AT THE- TO IN THIS
IMPROVE EQUITY I'M NOT.
CONGRESS BEEN LIGHTER
INCAPACITY I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
AYE BUT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WHAT PLEASE. GOOD MEMBER
OF THE TRY. COMMITTEE I AM L.
ORTIZ PRESS OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE ALAMEDA CONTRA
TRANSIT. AND A MEMBER OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION I AM HERE TO EXPRESS
BASIC PLAN TO SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOR FIFTY FIVE AC TRANSIT
SERVES APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION PEOPLE IN ALAMEDA
AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES
INCLUDING TRANSLATE SERVICE
ACROSS THE DUMBARTON SOME
THEY'LL SAN FRANCISCO AND
OAKLAND BAY BRIDGES. 65% OF OUR
WRITERS ARE LOW INCOME 29% HAVE
LIMITED ENGLISH LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY AND SEVENTY FIVE
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR PRIOR TO
THE TIME THAT MAKE OUR TRANSPAY
SERVICE PROVIDED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DAILY RIGHTS AND
RIDERSHIP WITH INCREASING. AB
FOUR FIFTY FIVE AUTHORIZES THE
CREATION OF TRANSIT ONLY LANE
ON THE BAY BRIDGE THE BAY
BRIDGE AND THE HIGHWAYS LEADING
INTO IT AT SOME OF THE MOST
CONGESTED CORRIDORS IN THE
STATE HOWEVER LAST MONTH
TRAFFIC LEVELS ON THE BAY
BRIDGE EXCEEDED 90% OF PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS WE NEED BLOCKS
LANES ON THE BAY BRIDGE. TO ME
THAT THE MAN REDUCE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION IMPROVE AIR QUALITY
AND CONNECT PEOPLE TO JOBS AND
RESOURCES WE HAVE WORKED WITH
LOCAL AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AGENCIES ON PROJECTS TO IMPROVE
BOSS ACCESS TO THE BAY BRIDGE
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IMPROVEMENT
HAVE LITTLE BENEFIT ONCE THE
BOXES REACHED BRIDGE BUSES ARE
GETTING STUCK IN TRAFFIC
SLOWING THE COMMUTE. AND
SLOWING PROGRESS TOWARD
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AB FOUR
FIFTY FIVE WILL INCREASE
CAPACITY ON THE BAY BRIDGE
IMPROVE MOBILITY AND
CONNECTIVITY AND PROMOTE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITABLE AND
SOCIAL BENEFITS OF RELIABLE
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGAIN I AM ALSO
TO PEACE IF THE TRANSIT BOARD
PRESIDENT AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
FIVE THANK YOU FOR.
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DO HAVE WITNESSES IN OFF
EITHER BY FOR OR IN THE ROOM OR
IN THE REMOTE ROOM. OKAY
HEARING NONE WE'RE GOING TO NOW
SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS. OR ANYBODY IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY ROOM TO SPEAK
EITHER IN FAVOR OR OPPOSED TO A
BEFORE FIFTY FIVE. SEEING NONE
THE OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST A V.
FOR FIFTY FIVE. FINLAY'S GERMAN
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB FOUR FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. ENSURE THIS TIME WE
DO OF ABOUT FIFTEEN IN OUR
QUEUE. OKAY PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES REMEMBER IT'S ONLY
NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. AND WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER TWO TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MATT ROBINSON WILSHIRE INTO
SCHNAUZER IN LINE. YEAH THE
SOLANO TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE NUMBER NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY SIX THESE GUYS. GOOD
AFTERNOON JUSTIN HIGHER PLEASE
TALK ABOUT LEADERSHIP GROUP ARE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NOW GO TO NUMBER TWO
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST KEEP ON
COMING UP THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT THANKS. WE NEVER TO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NIKITA KARATE
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORTING
THANK YOU. NEXT WE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
DEREK STATE CORN CARE OF THE
FAIR CREDIT WRITER UNIT IN
SUPPORT. NOW GO TO NUMBER TWO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS EMILY MAHER FELT FROM THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
SUPPORT. THANKS TO NUMBER ONE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DO BELIEVE BORN HAMMER CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR. NOW GO TO
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
THIS IS JOHN MAYER WITH THE
EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THIS IS NUMBER TWO
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DUNCAN MCFETRIDGE
REPRESENTING METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
NEXUS NUMBER SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FEYERABEND ALAMEDA
COUNTY FRANCE ALL RIGHT ALAMEDA
COUNTY TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT LOCAL BUT NOT. NEXT ME
NUMBER ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR NICCOLO
DELUCA ON BEHALF OF OAKLAND
MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M NOT
GONNA NUMBER SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I SAID I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I SUPPORT. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JANICE LEE AND I AM ELECTED
TO THE BART BOARD AND REPRESENT
THE WESTERN HALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF AB. FOUR FIFTY FIVE. NEXT WE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SERRA WILL BE
AND I'M A CALIFORNIA NATIVE AND
SAN FRANCISCO RESIDENT IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB WORK. FIFTY FIVE.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. PLEASE
CONTINUE MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
AT THIS POINT I WILL TAKE THIS
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS OR ANY COMMENTS.
MANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING
NONE OF WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
YET AS SOON AS WE DO WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL BUT I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL I'M A
BIG SUPPORTER OF TRANSIT THIS
A- BRIDGE LOST A LANE TO A-
TRANSIT LANE TO. A SINGLE
OCCUPANCY CARS IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES AND THIS WILL HELP TO
UNDO THAT I DON'T WANT TO
THINK- FIRST OF ALL MS WEEKS
FOR TAKING THIS BILL OVER FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA AND I
WANT TO THANK THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENTS
I'M- FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL TODAY. LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU OUR NEXT WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE OUT OF ORDER MR SANTIAGO
ON AB NINE OH SEVEN. MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE CAN PROCEED AS
SOON AS YOU'RE READY. I THINK
THE MANAGER AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK IN
THE COMMITTEE FOR HELPING US-
WITH THIS BILL TO MAKE A STRONG
ABILITIES DAY. AND AB NINE OH
SEVEN REDUCE FINES AND
PENALTIES FOR DRIVING WITHOUT A
LICENSE I WAS SUSPENDED LICENSE
FOR FAILING TO APPEAR IN COURT
TO TRAFFIC A VIOLATIONS. THESE
MINOR VIOLATIONS OFF OFTEN
RESULT IN EXTREMELY HIGH FINES
FEES AND SOMETIMES
INCARCERATIONS COULD
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- I
WILL BE BRIEF MA'AM IN RESPECT
pOVER TO WITNESSES J. WHO IS
IMPACTED PERSON. AND CLIENT A
PUBLIC COUNCIL AND SAID HE CAN-
I FELLOW AT WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE AND THE B. PROGRAM AT
A KOREAN AMERICAN SERVICES
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU MR
SANTIAGO DO YOU KNOW IF YOUR
WITNESSES ARE AVAILABLE BY
PHONE OR THE WITNESS ROOM BUT
IT SHOULD BE BY PHONE OKAY
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE BRING
ME WITNESSES FOR AB. NINE OH
SEVEN. OPERATOR WE'RE LOOKING
FOR THE WITNESSES FOR AB NINE
OH SEVEN SANTIAGO. AND I
WITNESSES ON THE LINE. DO I
START YES PLEASE. RED HAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER INSIDE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PENNY CHAM
THE LAST WEEK FINANCED PROGRAM
MANAGER AT THE FACTORY IN
AMERICAN FAMILY THIRTY SAID
ANYONE MENTALITY HELLO I AM
HERE TO SUPPORT 89% AND A BILL
CANDIDATE BUSH CANNOT MAKE THAT
DECISION FOR FAILURE TO APPEAR
IN TRAFFIC COURT AS WELL AS TO
MAKE MUCH DRIVING WITHOUT A
LICENSE VIOLATION AN INFECTION.
BETTER THAN ANYTHING IN.
CURRENT THERE ARE. SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE LIKE THAT LIKE
IF YOU CAN. IF YOU SEE AN
EXCEPT COURT. ACCORDING TO STOP
SIGN I KNOW THAT PUBLISHED IN
TWO FIFTEEN RECORDS FROM THE
COUNTY. DMV SHOW THAT BLACK AND
LYFT CAN ARKWRIGHT'S MARC. TO
YOUR LIFE. AND THAT THE AVERAGE.
THANK THAT MEMBERS OF INCOME
COMMUNITY AND CAñADA COLOR ARE
READY NOT. TO APPEAR IN COURT.
YOU COULD BARELY HEAR THAT HI
WHAT SCHEDULE HOME. AND
TRANSFER TO ISSUES ANY UP FOR A
OF HAVING HIM LIKE SUSPENDED AT
THE PENALTY FOR FAILURE TO
APPEAR. TO HARSH. THE PENALTY
HAS AT THE TO COLLECT
UNEMPLOYMENT TO BEGIN THE- AND
IT HAS FAR HARDER THAN MEN
BURKE WITH YOU CAN. WHO
HAPPENED TO CATCH. AND LITTLE
TO NO BLEEDING. EIGHTY NINE OH
SEVEN AUTHORED OF. TO BECOME
COMMITTEE ON VACATION AT THE IN
THE CODE. THAT DRIVING WITHOUT
A VIOLATION. BOB EIGHTEEN-
THANK YOU FOR. WITH THAT THERE
ARE NO. A CRIMINAL THEY CAN
DETERMINE. AB OH SEVEN WILL
BENEFIT LOW CAN. AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BY
REDUCING BY NOT THAT. FOR
FAILURE TO IN COURT AND WE DO
BY AND- BURKE ON A SUSPENDED
LICENSE. AND PUT THEM I ARE THE
COMMITTEE TO GO I UNABLE NINTH
AT AND. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. HELLO MY NAME IS
JAY A DIRECTLY AND CAN MEMBER
TO LICENSE COUNTY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB AND ALSO. I AM IF
FONG YOUTH HAD A THEY WILL BE
CAN. TWENTY EIGHT I'VE TRY AND
FOR TO DEVELOP INTO A FTA HOLDS
THE BEST I COULD NOT PRESENT A
CHANGE OF ADDRESS FORM AND DID
NOT POSSESS A DRIVER'S LICENSE
ON MOTHER'S DAY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN I WAS EXCITED TO SEE
MY MOTHER AFTER A LONG DAY OF
WORK. HOURS DRIVING FROM
CONTENT TO SOUTH CENTRAL AND I
GOT PULLED OVER FOR HAVING A
SUSPENDED LICENSE FOR FAILURE
TO APPEAR WHICH FORM THE BASIS
FOR MY CAR TO GET SO OFTEN ABLE
TO COVER MY CARD INTO A THIRTY
DAY HOLD IMPOSED BY THE CHP
POLICY SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
THEY WILL PAY FOR THE SENATE
LICENSE SO. WHICH LED TO FEES I
COULD NOT AFFORD THEN ABILITY
TO COVER MY CAR WAS HUGELY
DEVASTATING AFTER MY CAR WAS
TAKEN AWAY I HADTO TAKE OVER
TO AND FROM WORK SPENDING
FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN DOLLARS
EACH WAY. OUT OF FRUSTRATION I
WOULD WALK FROM DOWNTOWN LA TO
THE NEXT CITY JUST TO SAVE
MONEY PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION WAS
NOT ACCEPTABLE AT THE TIME
USING MY CARS VERY PAINFUL TO
ME BECAUSE IT WAS MY STABILITY
MY LIFELONG DREAM IS TO BECOME
A CERTIFIED MECHANIC AND OPEN
UP MY OWN SHOP. USING IT HURT
ME FINANCIALLY MOTION
GOVERNMENT DEEPER INTO POVERTY
THE WHOLE PREVENTING ME FROM
GETTING A LICENSE INSTEAD
PUBLIC COUNCIL HAS WORKED WITH
ME THIRD OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CITATION AND I'LL HAVE A
PERMIT. I'M SCHEDULED TO TAKE
MY BEHIND IT WILL TEST THIS
WEEK DRIVER'S LICENSE
SUSPENSIONS AND PENALTIES.
PLACED ADDITIONAL. BARRIERS ON
LOW TO USE THEM MAKE IT HARD TO
IT. THE BILL. REDUCING COUNTY
FORTY LONG. STATE RELATED
OFFENSE. WILL BENEFIT LOW. AND
OF COLOR HAD BEEN DISTRICT. AND
BY THE- OVERREACHING THE BLOCK.
THE DIESEL. OKAY BECAUSE WE
SAMPLE. FOR A NINE ALSO. I
THANK YOU VERY- WE'LL GO I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. WELL
I'M SORRY WHY DO WE HAVE A MUCH
BIGGER I'VE I APOLOGIZE WE WILL
MORE SPEAKER IN SUPPORT. GO
AHEAD. HERE PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE BUTTON. AT THE TIME I'M
ONLY SHOWING TWO SPEAKERS OKAY
THEN WE DO IS SEEING NO OKAY
ARE TERRIBLY ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION SO- ACTUALLY WE HAVE
DELIVERIES BECAUSE IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR. AT THAT
TIME I DON'T SHOW ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OKAY- I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE ANY SPEAKERS HERE
AND THE CHAMBERS- ATTORNEYS NO
SPEAKERS ARE NO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY- OPERATOR WILL YOU
OPEN UP THE LINE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WANT TO SPEAK- IN
SUPPORT. OF FOR THIS BILL. AB
NOW SEVENTY IF YOU'RE INTO THE
PORT THE- IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY NINE OH SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
TWO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS MIKE CARROLL OF
THE POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ARE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE I
TODAY ON EIGHTY NINE OH SEVEN
TO BRING JUSTICE. TO PERSON TO
WALK OF THE LICENSE OF SOLELY
BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT APPEAR
IN COURT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF TWO
FOUR EIGHT. GOOD EVENING CARE
MEMBERS PERSECUTOR ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRE. FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CAN WILL GO TO THE LINE OF.
TWO FOUR SEVEN. HI GOOD ON GOOD
EVENING CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MANIFESTED NINE ONE
WITHIN THE STATE'S GOING TO
CANNOT COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
PROJECT AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE OH SEVEN
THANK YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THE DEVELOPMENT
DIRECTOR STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
BROWN ISSUE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE SEVEN THANK YOU. WE
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF TWO FOUR
ONE THREE FIVE HAD. HELLO THIS
WILL BE A MEDIC- AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF A FEW
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS WHO
COULD BE PREGNANT. I'LL HAVE
LEGAL SERVICES OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS COMMITTEE
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF THE
CHEMICAL BAY AREA. ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS. ASIAN
WOMEN'S SHELTER ALLIANCE FOR A
BETTER COMMUNITY. MATT CHILD
NOT SHALL WE WISEMAN THAT'S AN
INDIVIDUAL- COMMITTEE
ENVIRONMENTAL COUNCIL. YEAH
WOMEN'S FREEDOM. ROUTE IN
REVENGE. WITHIN DRUG
INDIVIDUALS GENYA STRESS AND A
LACK ORGANIZATION IT'S
CULTURALLY RESPONSIBLE WITH THE
FUNDS THAT THE MASSIVE VIOLENCE
NETWORK NOW BUT HAD GREEN
AMERICAN FAMILY THERAPY. THANK
YOU IN SUPPORT. OF EIGHTY NINE
OH SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU WE WILL THE LINE OF
ONE NINE IF I HAD. HI
MADISONVILLE CUT OFF WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN THE WITH
THE LINE OF TWO ZERO EIGHT AT.
HI THIS IS LEE SJ HOME WITH THE
NATIONAL VISION ZERO NETWORK
BASED IN CALIFORNIA AND BOY TO
SUPPORT. AND THERE ARE NO OTHER
CALLERS INTO PORT AT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC I'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB NOW SEVEN
ONLINE. WE DO HAVE LINE NUMBER
ONE NINE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AT THIS REPORT NUMBER- VOICING
SUPPORT THANK. OKAY THANK YOU-
ANY OTHER CALLERS OPERATOR.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
OKAY- WILL NOT BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I BELIEVE WE HAVE
A QUESTION FROM AS A MEMBER
DAVIES THANK YOU MR SANTIAGO
FIRST OF ALL THERE'S NO
ARGUMENT PUBLIC SAFETY IS OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY. MY
QUESTION IS IF YOU COULD JUST
CLARIFY ON IN REGARDS TO-
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
BASICALLY- TWO TIMES- YOU KNOW
BEING PULLED OVER CHECK FOR
INFECTION IS THIS IF YOU'VE
ALREADY HAD A DRIVER'S LICENSE
YOU JUST DIDN'T RENEW IT OR
WOULD BE IF SOMEONE THAT DID
EVEN EVER GET THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE COULD ACTUALLY HAVE TWO
INFRACTIONS. OKAY LET ME LET ME
SEE WHAT THE BILL DOESN'T
HOPEFULLY UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION BASICALLY SAYING IS IF
YOU HAVE AN INFRACTION YOU
SHOULD HAVE A DRIVER'S LICENSE
TAKEN AWAY SO THAT HAPPENS- THE
FIRST TIME AS I AS I UNDERSTAND
WRITTEN THE WAY WE DRIVE TODAY-
YOU GET A HUNDRED DOLLARS OF
HAPPENED A SECOND TIME.
MEANING- THE GET ANOTHER
DOLLARS IN THE FOURTH SORRY THE
THIRD ONE- WOULD BE- FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS- BUT THERE ARE
CERTAINLY NAY I WOULD TELL YOU.
OTHER THINGS A JUDGE CAN DO OR
THE COURTS CAN DO BECAUSE-
OFTENTIMES PEOPLE SAY WHAT THE
TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE I TEMPOR
SAYS BUT THERE'S- THERE ARE.
FINES IF YOU COULD NOT-
INCREASE UP TO FIFTY PERCENT. I
CAN SEND FTD BUT WHAT THE CORE
OF THIS REALLY IS TRYING TO DO
IN THE DOES HAPPEN MYSELF
ALMOST RECENTLY- OR I- GOT A
SPEEDING AND- THE IN MY CASE I
WAS ABLE TO CATCH- THE DATE OF
WHEN I WAS SUPPOSED TO GO TO
COURT. AND THE HOME OF MISTY
BUT TO A MISSED IT- AND HAVE MY
DRIVER'S LICENSE SUSPENDED
SIMPLY BECAUSE I WON A FEW.
EXTRA A LITTLE BIT FASTER THAN
I PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE- MAKES
NO SENSE IN PARTICULAR WE'RE
TAKING A LOOK AT SOME- LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES IN WITH OUR
LANGUAGE BARRIERS. IT'S A HARSH
PENALTY TO TAKE SOMEBODY'S-
LICENSE AWAY. OVER AN
INFRACTION SO. I WOULD SAY I
WOULD SAY IT IS. I WANNA DANCE
QUESTIONS I. OKAY THANK YOU
AND- THE CAN JUST CLARIFYING
THIS TWENTY IF ANYTHING LIKE
THAT THE DO YOU AYE OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT AS WELL THE WAY I
UNDERSTOOD THE WAY WE DRAFTED
IS IT STILL ALLOWS FOR THE
JUDGES HAVE DISCRETION OVER
CERTAIN CATEGORIES- OF
INFRACTIONS IN THOSE WOULD
INCLUDE- DO YOU EYES RECKLESS
DRIVING AND CAUSING BODILY
HARM. THE REALLY WHEN TRAINING
OUT HERE IS. SOMEBODY FOR SOME
MISFORTUNE MAKES A RIGHT HAND
TURN. AND FOR SOME MISFORTUNE
CANNOT ATTEND. A COURT HEARING
DATE AND THEN HAS A- LICENSE.
SUSPENSION WHICH HAVE CAUSED
MUCH GRAVER DAMAGE AND
ULTIMATELY CUT COSTS. US A LOT
MORE THAN TO ALLOW THEM TO
CONTINUE WE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL
IN WHAT IS WHAT THEY'RE DOING
TO. BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT I ADDRESSED EXACTLY WHICH
SETS OF THOSE THREE CATEGORIES
OF JUST HOW TO SCRATCH. OKAY
AND THEN AGAIN JUST ONE PLAYER
FIND THIS WOULD BE IF YOU HAD
YOUR YOUR WHEN YOU GOT YOUR
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND SAY WAS
SUSPENDED OR OR SOMETHING LIKE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. BUT IF
SOMEONE IS PULLED OVER NEVER
GOT A DRIVER'S LICENSE DOES
THAT PERTAIN TO THAT AS WELL-
WELL THEY NEVER HAD A DRIVER'S
LICENSE IT WOULD BE SUSPENDED.
YOU WANT RECESSED SPENDING IT.
AT THE COURTS FOR NOT FOR
SHOWING UP FOR A FRACTION. OKAY
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
WINTER BE DIFFERENT. OF THEIR
CAUGHT DRIVING WITHOUT A
LICENSE DOT. HAVE GOTTEN. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPROVED.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. I AM GOING
TO ASK ANY THE MEMBERS WHO WERE
OUT OF THE ROOM TO COME BACK IN
SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM PLEASE AND WE CAN.
ACTUALLY VOTE ON THIS BILL. I
MISTER SANTIAGO I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL I WAS
CONCERNED ORIGINALLY. THAT WE
WOULD HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAD THEIR
LICENSE SUSPENDED FOR. DRUNK
DRIVING OR FOR. RECKLESS
DRIVING BE ABLE TO DRIVE AROUND
WITHOUT THAT LICENSE UP. I
PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT A
DRIVER'S LICENSE IS DRIVING IS
A PRIVILEGE NOT A RIGHT. AND
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A CERTAIN
BASIC LEVEL OF. COMPETENCE AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO IT. BUT
THIS BILL NOW HAS BEEN
NARROWED. TO FAILURE TO APPEAR
AND LEFT UP TO THE DISCRETION
OF A JUDGE AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT. THAT OFFENSE WOULD BE A
MISDEMEANOR SO I THINK THAT IT
DOES- REALLY HELP PEOPLE WHO.
REALLY SHOULD BE ABLE TO STILL
DRIVE- DO SO BUT KEEP DANGEROUS
DRIVERS OFF THE ROAD SO I THINK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY- CAN WE- WHAT'S
ESTABLISH A TERRIBLE WE CALL
RECALL. FRIEDMAN I HEAR. FONG
BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM DALY DAVIES
GIPSON KALRA LEE THERE. MEDINA
THE SYRIAN. WHEN DONALD. LORD
WICKS. NICOLE MISTER GIBSON
AGAIN. GIPSON WELL HERE. OKAY
WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW LET'S VOTE
ON THE BILL IF WE CAN EVER
RECALL ON THE BILL PLEASE. WE
HAVE A MOTION. AND WE HAVE A
SECOND NOW WE CAN HAVE A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MANY MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FRIEDMAN YES
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG NO BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY.
DAVIES NO DAVIS NOW GIPSON-
GIPSON AYE KALRA LEE. THREE I
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN I WENT. WHEN NO NO
DONALD. HI. OKAY CAN WE CALL MR
DALY MISTER KALRA PLEASE HELP
MR COLOR- KALRA. KALRA I DALY.
DAILY HI. DALY. KERBAL TEN
THREE TEN THREE THE BILL ITSELF
THANK YOU SANTIAGO I AM GOING
TO ASK YOU NOT TO APPROACH THE
DESK TO ADD ONTO VOTE- LATER ON
BECAUSE IT'S THE BEST NOT TO DO
THAT SO WE CAN TO BE CALDERON
AND SHOUT OUT YOUR RESPONSE-
FROM YOUR DESK THANK YOU HIS
CAREER YOU ARE UP I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BEING PATIENT
WITH US AND ALLOWING US TO TAKE
THE BILLS OUT OF ORDER SO THAT
A BUNCH OF US TO GO AND BUILD
ANOTHER COMMITTEE. HAVE THIS
NEXT BILL IS AB. NOW US. NINE
FOUR. I CARILLO AND A- PRIO
WHENEVER YOUR READY YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER-
AND- SORRY MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND JUST THE
JUST LAST WEEK I WAS TRYING TO
BALANCE THREE COMMITTEES AT THE
SAME TIME SO I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
POSITION THERE AND I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB SEVEN NINE FOUR THE
CRIME IS JOBS AND EQUITY
APTAMER THAT WOULD. FLEEING
VEHICLE AND INTO A TRUE AND FOR
I CAN RECOVERY GROWTH OF HIGH
CALL JOBS DISADVANTAGED WORKERS
BY ENSURING THAT PUBLIC FUNDING
TO PURCHASE CLEANER VEHICLES IF
TIED TO LABOR STANDARDS I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT THAT THE
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS THESE
CHANGES INCLUDE AMONG MANY
OTHER THINGS. EXCLUSIVELY AT
EXEMPTING OFF ROAD VEHICLE THE
THOMAS VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY AND
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE ALLOW
TIME FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO DETERMINE APPROPRIATE
NATIONAL CONTENT STANDARDS AND
DIRECT CARP TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY TO SET ACHIEVABLE
STANDARD ON DOMESTIC- CONTENT
AND ALSO GIVE CARD THE ABILITY
TO POSTPONE STANDARDS THAT ARE
NOT FEASIBLE MODIFY THE
REPAYMENT PROVISIONS OF
INCENTIVES AND NARAL COMPLIANCE
TO SERIOUS VIOLATIONS OF LABOR
LAW AND ALLOW FOR THE AN
APPEALS. AND REINSTATEMENT
PROCESS I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS MANUFACTURERS
FLEET PURCHASERS AND SPONSORS
TO ADDRESS OUTSTANDING ISSUES
NOT COVERED BY THESE AMENDMENTS
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
MOMENT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE AND OUR PARTNERS
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
STRATEGIES IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE COVER NINETEEN DOWNTURN IN
THE GOVERNOR'S THE CLIMATE
EXECUTIVE ORDER HAVE MADE THESE
INVESTMENTS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC EQUITY AND CLIMATE
TOOLS THIS BILL INCORPORATES
HIGH ROAD WORKFORCE STANDARDS
AND TO CALIFORNIA'S NEW CLEAN
VEHICLE INCENTIVE DOLLARS.
THESE STANDARDS WILL LEVERAGE
HIGH ROAD HIGH ROAD JOBS FOR
DISADVANTAGED AND DISLOCATED
WORKERS IN VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING BATTERY
PRODUCTION AND TRUCK DRIVING
WORKFORCE STANDARDS GUARANTEE
THE REPUBLIC DOLLARS DELIVER.
AT WE NEED TO STRONG CALIFORNIA
WORK. AND YOU WERE CALLA JOB IN
THE CVV TRANSIT. THIS IS
BECAUSE THAT COME PUBLIC THE
AND- COMPANIES TO FOR AT THEIR
FOR. DELIVER HIKES JOB AND TAKE
A- FOR MISSION. THE AUTO AND AS
A STORE OF A MONEY FOR TO AND
NEARLY TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA. AND ONE ONE MILLION.
PEOPLE NATIONWIDE. BUT JOB
QUALITY IN THE AUTO INDUSTRY
HAS BEEN COMPROMISED BY
OFFSHORING RELIANCE ON
TEMPORARY WORKERS. ATTACKS ON
WORKERS FREEDOM OF ASSOCIATION
AND WEEKEND HEALTH AND SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT. I WANT TO JUST FOR
INFLATION. WAGES WERE PUT.
WORKERS IN OTTAWA AND AUTO
PARTS OF DECLINE BY OVER 20% IN
THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS. THIS IS
WHY GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIES TO
AUTO COMPANIES NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE. HIGH QUALITY JOBS
THAT ARE BASED IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND LOS ANGELES PORK
TRUCK COURT TRUCKERS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MOVING ALMOST
HALF OF THE NATION'S CONTAINER
IMPORTS. OF THE ALLEY PORTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS OTHER AFTER
PORTS WITH MAJOR TRUCKING
OPERATIONS AS WELL. PORCH
ROCKING AND SHORT HAUL TRUCKING
GENERALLY ARE HOME TO AGREED TO
DISMISS CLASSIFICATION OF
CONTRACTORS. BY MAJOR
INTERNATIONAL CORPORATIONS
BETWEEN 7290% OF DRAYAGE TRUCK
DRIVERS ARE MISCLASSIFIED
MAKING THIS THE DOMINANT
BUSINESS MODEL IN THE INDUSTRY.
POLICIES AND INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
TO UPGRADE FLEETS WITHOUT LABOR
STANDARDS PUNISH HARDWORKING
DRIVERS AND INSURANCE MATH
CLASSIFICATION. USA TODAY
CALLED CONDITIONS AT THE LOS
ANGELES AND LONG BEACH PORTS
MODERN DAY INDENTURED SERVITUDE.
AFTER THE FIRST CLEAN TRUCK
PROGRAM. AS OFTEN TRUCK DRIVE
ARE NOW PAID BECAUSE OF TO MORE
FOR THE TWO RENTAL THEN THE
DRIVER FOR AND- WORKFORCE THAT
CAN BE TO SHOW THE BEST MODEL
AND TRUCKING. FROM EXTREME
WORKER EXPLOITATION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL NON COMPLIANCE TO
HIGH ROAD JOBS IN CLEAN
VEHICLES THAT DON'T POLLUTE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
LIKE THE ONES THAT I REPRESENT.
MY DISTRICT IS SURROUNDED BY
THE FIVE THE TEN THE SIXTY THE
ONE TEN THE TO THE ONE THIRTY
FOUR. AND PERHAPS THE SEVEN TEN
ANOTHER SEVEN MAY HAVE
FORGOTTEN. WE ARE SURROUNDED BY
FREEWAYS AND BETTER QUALITY. I
THOUGHT AB SEVEN NINE FOUR
CREATES A PATHWAY TO ENSURE
THAT PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS AND
FLEETS. PRESERVING GROW HIGH
QUALITY US IN CALIFORNIA JOBS
AND AUTO MANUFACTURING BY TYING
WORKFORCE STANDARDS TWO
INCENTIVE DOLLARS. THIS BILL
HELPS PRODUCE MUCH
CLASSIFICATION OF TRUCK DRIVERS
AND GUARANTEE THAT OUR
PRECIOUS. PUBLIC INVESTMENTS
DON'T SUBSIDIZE COMPANIES THAT
ILLEGALLY CLASSIFY THEIR
WORKERS AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS STILL THEIR WAGES
AND FAIL TO COMPLY WITH OUR
STATE ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS.
ADDITIONALLY AB SEVEN NINE FOUR
ENCOURAGES MANUFACTURERS TO
PRODUCE VEHICLES USING STATE OR
FEDERAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
OPERATOR TRAINING PROGRAM OR
PROVIDE A BLUEPRINT. FOR HOW
THEY EXPECT TO DELIVER TRAINING
TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL WORKPLACE
SKILLS. AT THIS CRITICAL MOMENT
OF AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY
TRANSFORMATION CALIFORNIA
CANNOT AFFORD TO FAIL ON
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIES TO
SOURCE LOCALLY. BOTH LOCAL AND
NATIONAL ECONOMIES AND BUILD
OUT CRITICAL MANUFACTURING
SUPPLY CHAINS WITH EQUITY. AND
JOB QUALITY GUARANTEES FOR THE
JOBS FOR THE FUTURE AVAILABLE
TO TESTIFY. OVER THE PHONE OUR
SERVER FLUX WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL AND SAM APPEL.
REPRESENTING THE BLUEGREEN
ALLIANCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR YOU PLEASE UP PHONE
FOR THE TO WITNESS AND SOME. OF
SURPLUS I BELIEVE IS FOR AND
THEN SAY I FELT. PLEASE PER ONE
TWENTY ONE POINT ZERO. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THERE ARE FLOCKS
ACTUALLY HERE REPRESENTING THE
TEAM PORT DIVISION ONE OF THE
PRODUCTS AT EIGHT SEVEN NINE
FOUR AND I JUST WANTED TO START
THINKING CHAIR MADAM CHAIR AND-
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR THE
REALLY HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
ON THE AMENDMENT- AND ALL THE
TIME AND ATTENTION THAT BEING
BACKED INTO IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE APPRECIATE IT. I'M
CLIMATE CHANGE DOESN'T IMPACT
OUR COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
WERE AROUND THE GLOBE HE
QUICKLY. LOW INCOME IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THEY'RE
THE WORST IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND POLLUTION. AND IT'S
OFTEN BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES
LIVING AND WORKING IN THE
PLACES WITH THE HEAD MOST
HEAVILY POLLUTED. THESE ARE
PLACES LIKE THE PORT. WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTRES IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE OR NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT THE AUTHOR REFERENCE
BETTER SURROUNDED ON ALL SIDES
BY THREE WAY. SO THE PRIMARY OF
AB SEVEN NINETY. IS THAT THE
STATE CLIMACOOL. ARE IN EXTRA
LINKED TO ECONOMIC JUSTICE
GOAL. IF YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
THE THREAT OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS INEQUALITY AND
EXPLOITATION THAT STANDS IN THE
WAY OF A MORE GREEN ECONOMY.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL DOES
IT TIED TOGETHER AND LINK LABOR
STANDARDS WE ARE IN THE- GOALS
WHICH ARE. THE OTHER SPOKE
ABOUT THE MEDICAL. OF PORT
DRIVERS. AND WHY IS SO TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE PORK CHOPS
ARE A MAJOR SOURCE OF EMISSIONS
AND THE ABILITY OF THE STATE TO
MEET CLIMATE GOALS DEPEND IN
LARGE PART ON COMPLETE
PURCHASERS TRANSITIONING TO
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKING FLEET.
YET A MAJOR OBSTACLE TO MEETING
OUR CLIMATE GOALS IS THE MIDDLE.
OF PORT TRUCK RIVERS AND THE
REASON IS THAT MISCLASSIFIED
DRIVERS ARE MAKING THE MINIMUM
WAGE AND A BARELY TAKING HOME
ENOUGH MONEY TO SURVIVE AFTER
THEY PAID FOR THE GAP AND
MAINTENANCE. OF THEIR EXISTING
TRUCK. THE DRIVERS NOT. THE
COMPANY SEGMENTS. THEM BY THE
THAT HAVE TO BEAR COST OF BY A
ZERO EMISSIONS. IT'S LOCKED IF
YOU COULD ON SORRY TO THE TWO
MINUTES AS POSSIBLE CAN JUST
FINISH UP. NO PROBLEM THEY
CAN'T TO THAT- AB. SEVEN NINETY
FOUR. THOSE OP. AND RICK THAT
WE PURCHASED COME. WITH LABOR
LAW TO MISS CLASS THE- WE LOOKS
TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND FOR THESE REASONS I URGE
ARRIVA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN FRIEDMAN THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SHANNON HOW CAN I
SERVICE CALIFORNIA'S MANAGE
WITH ALLIANCE. WE WERE ALLIANCE
OF THE COSTA OF AB SEVEN NINE
FOUR. WE'RE NOT OF TEN LABOR
AND WORKING. THANK THE NATURAL
DEFENSE COUNCIL UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS SIERRA CLUB
AN ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
AB SEVEN SEVEN NINETY FOUR THAT
WORK FOR STAND. TO INCREASE BUT-
OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND
COMPANIES IN THE FUTURE AUTOMAT.
RIGHT NOW EUROPEAN UNION AND
CLICKING THE WE NEED LOCAL
VEHICLE AND BATTERY COULD NOT.
MAJOR ARE OFFSHORING ADVANCED
PRODUCTION LINES AND GOOD JOBS
HELLO LATER OF THE WORLD. THIS
AIMS TO PROTECT THE ONE WORKERS
AND THIRTY THOUSAND. THAT BUILD
CARS IN MEDICINE FOR THEIR PART.
AT THE SAME TIME THE BILL ABOUT
INCREASE DEMAND FOR OUR BILL
PRESS. ENTER CAL PRODUCED. WE
NEED TO BUILD A ZERO EMISSION
FUTURE HELP WORK AND INCOME.
CAN THE- EIGHT SEVEN FOUR THE
LAKERS. GREENHALGH AND ARE-
ENVIRONMENTAL AND LABOR PARKING
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR AND
THE PRESIDENT THAT THAT TO THE
THING YOU DON'T ON THEIR
OPERATIONS YOUR CALL
TRANSFERRED. THE BILL THE
WINNING COLD HER CLIMATE.
REDUCE THE MAJOR BARRIER TO
VEHICLE THE THEIR MISSION
CRITICAL BUT IT'S NOT CLASS.
AND SHALL HAVE BUILD BETTER NOT
BE A MISSION TRIP. ECONOMY
EXTRA URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB
SAID NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
LIST. TWO ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AND ONE WHO A TWO.
LET'S START WITH THE THIS
ENOUGH TRICIA MODE. OPERATOR
PEOPLE OPEN UP THE LINE MISTER.
MISTER SMARTY LINE IS OPEN. AND
OUR STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SORTING OUT
REMAINING ISSUES OF THIS
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD LIKE TO
SEE MY REMAINING TIME TO MISS
ALEXANDER TO ADDRESS THE BILL'S
MANUFACTURING PROVISIONS
INTEREST THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND AUTHOR AGAIN FOR
THEIR WORK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT CALLER'S
MEREDITH ALEX. OPERA IF YOU CAN
OPEN THE LINE FOR MEDICAL EXAM
PLEASE. AND MEREDITH YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE CREE AND I'M
HERE TO HEAR BEHALF OF STAR ON
EXPECTING ARKANSAS WE ARE ALSO
ON APPRECIATIVE OF THE CAN
BURKE AND THE OP WORK AMENDING.
AND BRIEFLY ARM IN OVER TWO AND
SEVENTY COMPANIES IN OREGON
ACROSS THE TRANSPORTATION.
INCLUDE THE NATION LEADING
TERRORIST THE COMING INACTION
HELLO IN ITS CURRENT FORM THAT
I CAN PRINT AT THE BILL WOULD
JEOPARDIZE CAL ZERO EMISSION
THE GOAL. AND IS VERY PROUD
COMING IN ARE TRYING BRING YOUR
MISSION VEHICLE TO AT AS CAN
MEET REQUIRE FOR LIGHT MEDIUM.
HEAVY. STRONGLY RECOMMENDED
THAT THE DOMESTIC CONTENT
PROVISION BE REMOVED UCW
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TECHNOLOGY
IS THAT AT THIS TIME IT'S
FASTER TO PURGE THE BITING
MINISTRATION IN CONGRESS TO
DETERMINE WHAT'S APPROPRIATE
AND STATE BY STATE STANDARDS
ARE REALLY NOT BE WORKABLE. AND
WE ALSO REQUEST THAT THE BILL
BE RESTRUCTURED TO PROVIDE
INCREASED INCENTIVE FOR
QUALIFYING ANY FACTORS RATHER
THAN LOWERED INCENTIVE THAT
WOULD BE DEFINITELY EASIER TO
ADMINISTER AND WE THINK ARE
APPROPRIATE SO IN ADDITION TO
THE POSITIVE AMENDMENTS-
DISCUSSED. HI MR SHIMODA. AND
ALCOHOL DISCUSS THEIR JUST ON
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN WOULD BE.
IN INCLUDING. THAT MINOR LABOR
BY. WOULD NOT RESULT- THAT
DON'T RESULT IN IT WORKER HARM
WOULDN'T COUNT AGAINST TO
MANUFACTURE AND MORE CLEARLY
DEFINING WHAT LABOR VIOLATIONS
ARE. AND PACIFYING FINAL
DECISIONS IN VERY IMPORTANT.
AND ALSO THE REQUIREMENT AS IT
APPEARS TO BE RECOMMENDED TO BE
REMOVED THAT MANUFACTURERS MUST
ESTABLISH A THREE YEAR
COMPLIANCE RECORD. UNDERSTOOD
UNFAIRLY PENALIZED NEW MARKET
ENTRANTS WHICH OF COURSE WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE- IT'S EITHER
MEN AND OUR DOCTOR DOES
DESCRIBE WE WOULD HAVE. HAD A
FEW REMAINING CONCERNS OF NOTE
AND THIS BILL WOULD STILL PUT
CALIFORNIA'S MANUFACTURED. ON
AN UNEVEN FOOTING BY ALLOWING
OUT OF STATE MANUFACTURERS TO
COMPLY WITH LOWER LABOR
STANDARDS LIKE. PLACES LIKE
ALABAMA AND TENNESSEE- AND I
THINK WE STILL REALLY NEED HER
THOUGHTFULLY CONSIDER THE
DIVERSION OF INCENTIVE DOLLARS.
FROM THE G. CARE ACT PROGRAM
THROUGH ENFORCING PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL IF YOU CAN. PLEASE.
YOUR YOUR OFFICE UP. YEAH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN WE HAVE
THAT WORK- COMMITTEE AND- THE
PHONE THIRDS WILL TO IN AND
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DESERVED IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK FOR OR AGAINST
THE BILL. IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE WITNESS ROOM. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE WITH THAT OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
SUPPORT POSITIONS FOR OR
AGAINST. EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR AGAINST
AB SEVEN NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE DAY IN JAIL AT THE
TIME. WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE SEVEN
ONE THREE FIVE HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE FOUR
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS IDEOLOGICAL
OF FROM JAPANESE AMERICA AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER TWO ONE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. MY NUMBER TWO FIVE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONCE
AGAIN THAT IT LINE NUMBER TWO
FIVE NINE. CHECK YOUR MUTE
BUTTON. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON TO
MY NUMBER TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ALLERGIC YOU KNOW
WITH UNITED AUTO WORKERS REGION
EIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER TWO TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LORD DID NOT HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. MY NUMBER
TWO FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CHEN MEMBERS ON HOW THAT WOULD
ON WITH WIDENING GROUP ON
BEHALF OF ELECTRIFY AMERICA YOU
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THE BILL BUT WE WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH DOCTOR
SOCKETS TO FURTHER CLARIFY THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT FIND IT EASY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND IS
NOT INTENDED TO MODIFY THE
FEDERAL COURT ORDER UNDER.
WHICH ELECTRIFY AMERICA YOU
SUPERIOR LOOK WE'RE NOT A WE'RE
NOT ACCEPTING TESTIMONY AT THIS
TIME JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION WHAT DO YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE OR IN BETWEEN
IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN THAT TO
SAY YOU'RE WELCOME TO RIGHT
RIGHT. US FOR THE WEBSITE THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. AND NUMBER TWO
ONE SEVEN WEEKS I HAD. HELLO
THIS IS A LEASE CONTRACT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. I NUMBER
TWO ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS MICHAEL MANY
ASSEMBLY HALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR NEW
ECONOMY IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
TWO ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRWOMAN
FRIEDMAN AND MEMBER SIMON WAY
WITH NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN NINETY FOUR TO PROMOTE
HIGH QUALITY JOBS IN EQUITY
TOGETHER WITH THE STATE THE
VEHICLE THANK. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWO SIX ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TO GET MY NUMBER TWO
SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
WE HAVE NO RESPECT FOR THAT
LINE. WITHOUT THE LETTER NO
OTHER COLLEGE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITHOUT
WILL GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
QUESTIONS. FRAZIER FONG. A
DESERVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS-
TO THE AUTHOR- I WAS WONDERING
IF YOU COULD- GIVE US AN
EXPLANATION OF WHY- WHY WILL
WHAT THE CARP ROUTE IN TERMS
OF- BEING THAT THE- THE
AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE LABOR MORE
POOR STANDARDS- AS OPPOSED TO
THE CALLOSUM. DEMI THIS CAR
HAVE THE BANDWIDTH. TO EVALUATE
LABOR COMPLIANCE- TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE THINKING BEHIND.
THAT DECISION. SURE MADAM
THIRTY WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO.
THANK YOU- SO RIGHT NOW I'LL BE
CALIFORNIA LABOR COMMISSIONER
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
INFLUENCE TO ACTUALLY- SEE HOW
MANY LABOR VIOLATIONS ARE
CURRENTLY- IN PROCESS- AND HOW
MANY OF THE- ASSIST THE TRUCK
DRIVERS ARE IN ASSOCIATION ALSO
AND NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
LABOR LAW. HOWEVER THOSE
REPORTS ARE NOT ALIGNED WITH
CARP THE GOAL WHICH I THINK WAS
MENTIONED I'M IN ONE OF THE
CALLS THAT WERE WITNESSES IN
THAT CAR WAS ACTUALLY THE ONE
THAT- CHALLENGED AND PASSED
WITH TRULY DEFINING
CALIFORNIA'S. EMISSION GOALS
AND CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
ALIGNMENT TOGETHER SO THAT THE
LABOR DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
CARP PASSED THE DATA THAT THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE IN
COMPLIANCE THAT'S WHY WE'VE
ALSO ADDED A FOR YOUR
PROVISION. AND ALL OF THE
PROVISIONS AND AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN TO ENSURE THAT
CAR HAS THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE
TO DETERMINE HOW WE MOVE THIS
FORWARD. OKAY DO YOU MIND
MOVING A LITTLE CLOSER TO THE
MIKE THAT'S A REALLY HARD TO
HEAR YOU BACK HERE CHECK. SORRY
ABOUT THAT THANK AYE SO I. I
CAN. I CAN APPRECIATE- THAT
SENTIMENT I GUESS THAT MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE HAVE. WELL
WE'RE LINKING TWO THINGS THAT
ARE KIND OF APPLES AND ORANGES
SO YOU HAVE I'M SORRY WHAT TO
THINK THAT WHAT WE WERE LINKING
TO THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO SAY
WE HAVE WE'RE LOOKING LIVE OVER
FOR STANDARDS TO LIKE EVEY
INCENTIVES- WHICH WOULD GO TO
THE CONSUMER NOT TO THE
MANUFACTURERS SO WE'RE- WE'RE-
WE'RE KIND OF. PUTTING THOSE
TWO THINGS TOGETHER SO I GUESS
THAT IS A MAYBE IT LEADS TO MY
SECOND QUESTION IS THAT. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE MANUFACTURER. TO
REIMBURSE THE STATE IN THE
EVENT THAT IS A VIOLATION. EVEN
THOUGH THE EEVEE INCENTIVES GO
TO THE CONSUMERS NOT THE MAIN
FACTORS SO I WAS MAYBE YOU CAN-
EXPLAINED. THAT THE THOUGHT
PROCESS THERE SO PUBLIC DOLLARS
THAT ARE USE FOR ANY TYPE OF
INCENTIVE AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE. IS ALONG THE REAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT A JUST
TRANSITION. SO AS LARGEST. WE
OFTEN TALK ABOUT WHAT A JUST
TRANSITION OF WORKERS LOOKS
LIKE FIVE YOU'RE SEEN THAT PLAY
OUT IN THE CONVERSATION AROUND
FOSSIL FUELS AND FOSSIL FUEL
EMISSIONS AND THE WORKERS THAT%
WORK AT. REFINERY THIS IS A
VERY SIMILAR CONVERSATION AND
IT SEEMS A LITTLE STRANGE
BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY HAS NEVER
BEEN DONE. PART OF THE
COMMENTARY THAT I RECEIVED ON
THIS BILL. EVEN WHEN WE ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT PRIORITIES
FOR SOME OF THE CAUCUSES IS
THIS A LABOR BILL. OR IS THIS
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BILL
IT'S BOTH. AND THAT'S THAT'S
THE SITUATION AND CONUNDRUM
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES IN. IS
THAT HOW ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO
ADDRESS TRANSITION OF WORKERS.
AND ENSURE THAT THE WORKERS
HAVE ACCESS TO RESOURCES A GOOD
JOB. INCENTIVES BENEFITS ALL OF
THOSE THINGS WITHOUT BEING
MISCLASSIFIED. AND TYING IT
INTO LABOR LAW AND TYING IT
INTO ONE OF OUR MENTAL CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS. THAT THE FAITH
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES IN. AND
THAT'S WHY YES IT'S NEW IT'S
INNOVATIVE IT HASN'T BEEN DONE
BEFORE AND THOSE ARE. THE
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK YOU AND
I ANOTHER CONVERSATION HAVE
ALSO TRIED TO ANSWER. AND SO WE
HOPE THAT THIS IS. IF YOU KNOW
ALL SITUATION GIVEN THEY HAD
MOVED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IS THAT IT ACTUALLY SET THE
TONE IT ACTUALLY SET THE
PATHWAY. OF THE OF A JUST
TRANSITION AND WHAT THAT COULD
ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE BOTH FOR
WORKERS FOR EMPLOYERS AND FOR
OUR ENVIRONMENT. IN THIS IT
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED THIS WOULD
APPLY TO ALL MANUFACTURERS.
CORRECT YES IN CALIFORNIA. OKAY
I HAD- I AM. I GUESS I'M I'M
I'M A LITTLE UNEASY SO I MEAN I
PLAYED BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
ANSWERS THANK YOU SURE- I WAS%
NOTIFIED THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
LEAST ONE CALLER WHO'S IN Q.
WHO WASN'T CALLED ON SO I'M
ACTUALLY IF YOU USE THAT ARE
PART IN THE- MISS CREO- I'M
GONNA ASK THE OPERATOR TO GO
BACK AND OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY WAS
IN QUEUE. FOR EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY FOUR HAD A CHANCE TO
GIVE THEIR TESTIMONY OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES AGAIN. FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THE TIME. WE WILL CLOSE THE
LINE NUMBER TWO SEVEN ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER TWO
SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON.
I HAVE NO RESPONSE FROM THAT
LINE WE WILL GO TO MY NUMBER
TWO SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
VENTURE MEMBERS MANUALLY ON
BEHALF OF TEST LIVE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION- WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WE STILL
BELIEVE THE BILL PUTS
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO OTHER
COLLEGE INTO OKAY CHRISTY THANK
YOU- THERE ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO SPEAK
MISTER BERMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WANNA THINK THE
AUTHOR- AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE WITH THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL TO ENSURE THAT OUR
TRANSITION AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS IS A JUST TRANSITION THAT
CREATES HIGH QUALITY JOBS FOR
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED. BY
AIR POLLUTION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
FLEET PURCHASING PART OF THIS
BILL BUT I HAVE MAJOR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL THAT APPLIED TO VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS. I SUPPORT THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT MANUFACTURERS
COMMIT TO HIRING DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS HAVE BEEN DISLOCATED
FROM THE FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY
AND PARTICIPATE IN JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS THIS COMMITMENT SHOULD
BE THE BASIS OF ADDRESS TRANSIT
YEAH I'M A JUST TRANSITION AS-
THE AUTHOR HAS HAS. SPOKEN
ABOUT HOWEVER THIS BILL
CONDITIONS CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING FOR MANUFACTURERS ON
COMPLIANCE WITH LABOR LAWS IN
THE STATE WHERE THE VEHICLE IS
MANUFACTURED. I WORRY THAT
COMPANIES TO MANUFACTURE IN
STATES LIKE ALABAMA WILL HAVE A
MUCH LOWER COMPLIANCE BAR TO
MEET AND THUS HAVE EASIER
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA STATE
FUNDED INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THEN
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
COMPANIES. I DON'T SEE HOW THIS
INCENTIVIZES GOOD LABOR
PRACTICES GOOD PAYING JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA OR HELPS US REACH
OUR CLIMATE GOALS- AND I KNOW
THAT THIS IS NOT THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT. DOES SO AND I'VE SPOKEN
WITH THE AUTHOR ABOUT THIS I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL IN
COMMITTEE TODAY BUT I DO WANT
TO BE CLEAR TO THE AUTHOR AND
TO THE SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL. THAT OF THE
PROVISIONS AROUND MANUFACTURING
ARE NOT EITHER TAKEN OUT OR
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED I'LL HAVE
NO CHOICE BUT TO VOTE NO ON THE
FLOOR AND. AND RAISE THE SAME
CONCERNS AT THAT TIME. THANK
YOU MR MEDINA THANK YOU- THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORD AND I JUST WANNA ECHO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALO ALTO AND-
BUT I DID HEAR THE AUTHOR SAY
IN HER REMARKS THAT SHE IS.
GONNA BE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION- WITH THEIR CONCERNS
AND AGAIN JUST TO- EXPRESSED MY
CONCERNS ALSO ON THE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF IMPACTS IT COULD
HAVE ON CALIFORNIA A COMPANIES
AND URGE THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
TO WORK. OF IN IN THAT
DIRECTION I WILL ALSO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU
MISSED WHEN DID YOU. I WANTED
CAN I ALSO MADAM CHAIR CAN I
ASK A QUESTION. YES FOR FUN.
RIGHT WELL APPRECIATING-
AUTHOR. AND YOUR EFFORT MIGHT I
GUESS KIND OF A STATEMENT SLASH
QUESTION IS. MY CONCERN IS THAT
THIS IS SO AGGRESSIVE THAT MY
FEAR IS THAT YOUR- HERE SETTING
THESEFLEET PURCHASER OF
FAILURE BY MAKING INCENTIVES
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN
RATHER THAN EASIER- BECAUSE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
MANDATES YOU HAVE IN HERE IT'S
MORE OF LIKE OKAY. THERE'S NO
POINT. OF THE SECOND AND THE
OTHER PART IS. THIS DOESN'T
AFFECT PUBLIC TRANSIT BUSES
RIGHT. NOT ONE NOT. THAT'S NOT
THE FOCUS OF THE BILL. DOES
THIS AFFECT SAY A NONPROFIT. IF
THEY'RE PURCHASING SAY BUSES
FOR THEIR ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE
I KNOW A LOT OF NON PROFITS IN
MY DISTRICT LET THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB EXEDRA THEY ARE THEY
HAVE BUSES THAT THE BUS KIDS TO
SCHOOL. THEY'RE NOT A- PUBLIC
TRANSIT. THEY'RE NOT A PRIVATE-
WOULD THEY BE AFFECTED BY THIS.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO RESPOND.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY THAT
NONPROFIT INCENTIVES WORK ARE
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT THAN. WHAT
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS
WHICH IS ABOUT MATH
CLASSIFICATION OF PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS AS WELL AS
INCENTIVIZING THE MANUFACTURING
OF- MORE GREEN TECHNOLOGY-
VEHICLES BOTH AND MEDIUM AND
HEAVY LIFT TRUCKS- THERE IS
THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS TO BE
HAD IN TERMS OF. WHAT IS THE
TRUTH JUST TRANSITION OF
WORKERS LOOK LIKE WHICH IS WHAT
WE HOPE TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
WITH THIS BILL. NOT QUITE SURE
THAT NONPROFIT BUYING OF. OF A
BUS FOR THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB
NECESSARILY FALLS IN LINE WITH
THIS. KIND OF DOES A COMMON
MADAM MADAM CHAIR I AM. WE'VE
SEEN NOW MORE THAN EVER THAT
OUR BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT IN
CALIFORNIA IS JUST BEEN VERY
VERY DIFFICULT AND I SEE THIS
AS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
CONTINUES MANDATE. THAT'S JUST
GOING TO BRING ALL THESE
MANUFACTURERS AND GIVING THEM
AN INCENTIVE TO LEAVE AND SO I.
I'M REALLY REALLY CONCERNED
THAT JUST THE TRIGGER EFFECTIVE
AS ONE AFTER ANOTHER AFTER
ANOTHER WE'RE GONNA START
LOSING A LOT OF THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ALREADY AND WE CAN
CONTINUE TO LOSE THOUSANDS OF
MORE JOBS. BECAUSE OF BILLS
LIKE THIS THAT MAKES IT MORE
ONEROUS. THAN AN INCENTIVE TO
COMPLY SO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER WARD. THANK
THAT MORE THAN ONE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ON
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
I THINK AS YOU HAVE MENTIONED
IN YOUR STATEMENT AS WELL IT'S
CREATED SOMETHING NEW- AND FOR
THE BENEFIT OF THE PUBLIC IN
ANY SOME OF THIS ROOM I WONDER
IF YOU COULD BECAUSE THIS IS A
NEWISH CONCEPT AND WE TALK
ABOUT IT BUT WE REALLY GOTTA
SLOW DOWN AND EXPLAIN. WHAT IS
A JUST TRANSITION. WELL A JUST
TRANSITION- IS REALLY ABOUT
ENSURING THAT AS WE- GO FORWARD
WITH CALIFORNIA. GOALS THAT WE
JUST PASSED SB ONE HUNDRED THAT
WOULD MANDATE 1100% RENEWABLE.
VEHICLES BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF. GOALS TO
END FOSSIL FUELS- THE USE OF
FOSSIL FUELS HERE IN THE STATE-
ENDING FRACKING IN THE STATE.
BUT ALL OF THOSE JOBS. ALL OF
THOSE- INDUSTRIES HAVE JOBS.
THE PEOPLE RELY ON. AND SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN TO HAVE
CONVERSATION OF SHUTTING THINGS
DOWN. A REAL CONVERSATION THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE IS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
TRANSITION. THOSE WORKERS WERE
EARNING A- SPECIFIC SALARY. AND
WHO ARE ALSO GOOD UNION JOBS.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
BE INCENTIVIZED TO. GO TO A
CLEANER- TECHNOLOGY. WILL NOT
LOSING THEIR JOB WHILE STILL
BEING ABLE TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE.
HEALTH BENEFITS WITH THEIR
UNION TO BE ABLE TO PUT THEIR
KIDS THROUGH SCHOOL. THERE IS A
HUMAN BEING ATTACHED TO THE JOB
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT. IT
JUST TRANSITION ENSURES THAT WE
ARE. TALKING ABOUT THE PERSON
FIRST. AS WE THINK ABOUT. OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS AS WE
THINK ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES HOW WE THINK
ABOUT ELEVATING. OTHER
INDUSTRIES. IF WE'RE TRULY
GOING TO. BUILD BACK. BETTER
AND HAVE FEDERAL STANDARDS AND
FEDERAL MANDATES THAT ARE BEING
ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT RIGHT NOW
IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE- ACTUALLY
GET. TO CLEAN GREEN. ENERGY
THESE ARE THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE NEED TO HAPPEN AND THEY
IN MY OPINION CANNOT HAPPEN.
WITHOUT TALKING ABOUT THE
WORKERS AND THE PEOPLE. WHO DO
THESE JOBS. AND SO THE WHOLE.
GOAL HERE IS TO ACTUALLY. MERGE
FOR THE FIRST. LAKE AND
STANDARDS THAT'S WHAT THANK YOU
THAT'S WHY. IT'S A HEAVY LIFT
AND IT'LL IT'S A GOOD
CONVERSATION TO BE HAVING. IN
TERMS OF WHAT WHAT IS IT REALLY
LOOKED LIKE. AND SO WE CAN TALK
ABOUT IT OR WE CAN ACTUALLY TRY
TO DO POLICY THAT HELPS US GET
THERE THANK YOU MISS BROWN I
AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND I WHY
I THINK THIS IS SO CREATIVE
DESIGN I TRIED TO SIMPLIFY IT
MAY BE SOMETHING THAT. I
ALREADY KNOW THAT IS A AYE
CONSUMER AYE YOU SLICE ONCE AND
THAT'S THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAM SO WE HAVE THIS PROGRAM
WHICH IS EXHAUSTED WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD MORE DEMAND FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO PURCHASE ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
SO MUCH SO THAT THE AMOUNT THAT
WE PUT OUT THERE AND ACTUALLY
BEEN- CONSUMED OUT THERE AND SO
WHEN WE WHEN WE SEE THIS
INTEREST OUT THERE THIS DEMAND
FROM CNSUMERS AS DEMAND FROM
COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THE MOMENT. AND ACTUALLY DO
MORE WE'RE IN A POSITION NOW TO
BE ABLE TO TIRE POLICIES
TOGETHER AND SEE WHAT OTHER
KIND OF COAL BENEFITS COULD WE
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE. THROUGH
IDEAS LIKE THIS OF THIS CONCEPT
THAT WE SEE HERE AND ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY FOUR SMART. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING OUT FOR OTHER AREAS OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE IN
MANY OF OUR AREAS OF
LEGISLATIVE. ABILITIES AND I
JUST REALLY WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR TIRING TYING THESE
TWO TOGETHER BECAUSE I DON'T
SEE THIS. IS SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO TURKEY- ADDITIONAL
ACTIVITY OUT THERE I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
ACTUALLY. INCENTIVIZE THE
MARKET PLACE TO BE ABLE TO TRY
TO COMPETE WITH EACH OTHER TO
MEET HIS EXACTING STANDARDS AND
THEN MORE CALIFORNIANS ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO WIN BECAUSE
OF THIS. FOR THE SAME POTS OF
MONEY FOR THE SAME KINDS OF
THINGS ARE DOING YES I
APPRECIATE YOU MIGHT BE LOOKING
AT SOME- OPTIONS FOR AND THEN
IS TO TRY TO. MAKE IT MAKE IT
WORK SO THAT THIS IMPLEMENTS
WELL ON BECAUSE IT REALLY COULD
BE TRANSFORMATIVE ON HOW WOULD
YOU POLICY I THINK BEYOND.
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR ITSELF
SO WITHOUT AND HAPPY TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR ALL THE EFFORT.
YOU PUT INTO THIS. THANK YOU
MISS. LEE I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE ARE DIFFERENT BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD AS REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE ONLY CAR MANUFACTURING
SITE IN THE STATE AS WELL AS
THE ONLY EVEY MANUFACTURING
SITE IN THE STATE I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO MAKE SURE IN
THOSE WORKING FOR US TO MAKE WE
MAKE SURE WE HAVE A GREENER
ECONOMY ARE ALSO NOT LEFT
BEHIND IN THE BENEFITS OF THE
GREEN ECONOMY. AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO VERY TO CALARE
PUT YOU SAW THE COMMENTS I WAS
GONNA SAY BUT YOU KNOW THE
MARKET IS THERE THE DEMAND IS
THERE ESPECIALLY IN THE BAY
AREA WHERE THESE CARS ARE BEING
MANUFACTURED- AND I REALLY
THINK IT'S REASONABLE STANDARDS
THAT YOU'RE SITTING OUT THERE
AND MAKING SURE THAT YOU KNOW
WE AVOID THE NOT SO PLEASANT
HEADLINES ABOUT PEOPLE BEING
MISTREATED AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE BEING TREATED WELL AND
MAKING SURE THAT CONSUMERS ARE
PART OF THAT TALK AS WELL. I
KNOW THAT YOU CAN TAKE THE
AUTHOR HAS BEEN TAKING A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS TO CAUGHT TO
ACCOMMODATE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE HAPPENING
AND SO I THINK THAT'S
INCREDIBLY RESULTS SO VERY
HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTING THIS AND
REALLY HAPPY. THAT YOU BROTHERS
BEFORE. THANK YOU MS WORKS. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I ALSO-
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
PARTICULARLY YOUR ARTICULATION
OF THE CONCEPT OF JUST
TRANSITION AND YOU KNOW MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE REFINERIES
THERE. AND THERE IS NO DOUBT WE
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
MOVE OFF OF FOSSIL FUELS AND WE
KNOW THIS AND THE SCIENCES
THERE AND IS THE MOTHER OF A
FOUR YEAR OLD AND NOW NINE
MONTHS OLD TODAY NINE MONTHS
TODAY. YOU KNOW I LOOK AT THEIR
FUTURE AND THE WORLD THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO LIVE IN. AND
WE DON'T HAVE A CHOICE I ALSO
KNOW WE HAVE GOOD PAYING UNION
JOBS RIGHT THAT ARE- THAT FEW
PEOPLE FAMILIES AND THE BALANCE
OF THOSE TWO THINGS AND HOW YOU
DO THAT. IT IS NOT AN EASY
QUESTION TO TACKLE BUT IT'S A
CRITICAL ONCE I WHEN IT
ACTUALLY THANK YOU FOR THAT
I'LL BE SPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. I'M GLAD YOU'RE JUMPING
ON THIS I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU IN THE SPACE OR OTHERS- TO
THAT END. I DO HAVE A QUESTION
THOUGH ALSO JUST THAT WAS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION. AND
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT- SOME
MEMBER BERMAN AND TOUCHED ON
I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT IT THIS
IDEA THAT- MANUFACTURERS FROM
OTHER STATES ALMOST HAVE A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE. THEY
WOULD HAVE THE SAME LABOR
CENTER COULD YOU JUST ADDRESS
THAT- IT WOULD BE HELPFUL. SURE
WE TOOK A NUMBER OF- OF
AMENDMENTS TO HELP. ALSO
CLARIFIED THAT TO LET ME JUST
MAKE SURE THAT- WE HVE THE
LATEST INFORMATION FOR YOU AND
I'M I'M HAPPY TO DISCUSS.
BECAUSE IT'S TRUE- WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT WHERE. AT IN THE
ASSEMBLY PART OF THE
MANUFACTURING IS A BIG PART OF
THE QUESTION TOO IF- IF A
BUMPER IS MADE IN CHINA AND
THEN. BROUGHT TO THE U. S. AND
MANY FISH AND PUT AN ASSEMBLED.
IN A FACTORY IN DETROIT. IS
THAT CONSIDERED AMERICAN MADE.
SO THOSE ARE A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF LIKE WHAT
DETERMINE SOMETHING TO BE. U.
S. MADE OR NOT- THE SAME. AS
STANDARD AS APPLYING TO WORDS-
DIFFERENT STATES AND WHAT WE
AGREED TO. ONE IS THAT THE
BIGGEST- COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGES
MANUFACTURERS AND OTHER STATES
HAVE IS ACTUALLY OW WAGES IN
RIGHT TO WORK LAWS WHICH ARE
VERY DIFFERENT. THAN CALIFORNIA
STATE LABOR LAWS. SO THE
MINIMUM WAGE FOR EXAMPLE IN
ALABAMA AND SEVEN DOLLARS AND
TWENTY FIVE CENTS. FAR BELOW.
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS. AB SEVEN
NINE FOUR REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS TO PAY A HUNDRED
AND 20% OF THE CALIFORNIA.
MINIMUM WAGE FOR ALL WORKERS
AND THE PREVAILING WAGE FOR
PRODUCTION WORKERS. IN AUTO
MANUFACTURING TO QUALIFY. SO WE
ARE SETTING THE TONE
DIFFERENTLY. WE ARE SETTING A
DIFFERENT AGENDA. WE ARE SAYING
WE WANT TO CREATE JOBS. WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THE JOBS THE
HERE THAT WE ARE EMPLOYING.
AMERICAN WORKERS TO DO. WHAT WE
ALL WANT TO DO WHICH IS ACHIEVE
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS AND
ENSURE THAT. PRODUCTION
MANUFACTURING ASSEMBLING TAKES
PLACE HERE. THOSE ARE THE
MANDATE TO BUILD BACK BETTER
AND CALIFORNIA. IS ALREADY
LEADING ON THAT UNTIL. THE YES.
IF COMPLICATED BIG. WE'VE TAKEN
A LOT OF AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT
BETTER WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK. WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ENSURE THAT WE GET IT RIGHT. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IN THE
WORK THAT I DO HEAR. THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING. MORE JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE CREATING
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE.
IN THE- STATES. IF WE ARE TRULY
GOING TO ACHIEVE. THE PILLARS
OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL WHICH IS.
A JUST TRANSITION. AMOUNT ENJOY.
INCOME CHANGE. APPROPRIATE THAT
AND- YOU KNOW A THE FACT THAT
YOU HAVE WITHIN BERMAN GROUPS
AND LABOR GROUPS COMING
TOGETHER ON THIS WHICH I THINK
IS CRITICAL SO JUST APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. MR DALY THANK YOU I
JUST BRIEFLY- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I DO
HAVE CONCERNS- ALIGNED WITH THE
POINTS MADE BY THE MEMBER FROM
PALO ALTO IN THE MEMBER FROM
RIVERSIDE- THIS IS VERY VERY
AMBITIOUS BILL AND- I'LL BE
WATCHING THE AMENDMENTS AS THEY
COME FORWARD AND HOPE THAT-
EVERYTHING COULD BE ALIGNED
AMONG ALL THE VARIOUS GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES WILL PEOPLE. YES DID
YOU EVER HAVE A QUESTION OR
COMMENT. OKAY ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBER WISHING TO
SPEAK. WELL I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND BRINGING IT
BEGINNING THE VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE HAVE
A REAL JUST TRANSITION- I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU PARTICULARLY.
YOUR SPONSORS FOR BEING SO
WILLING TO WORK WITH US AND TO
ADDRESS. OUR CONCERNS WHICH
WERE MANY AND TO TAKE SO MANY
AMENDMENTS IN GOOD FAITH AND TO
MAKE THIS REALLY A VERY EASY
PROCESS- TO MOVE TO A SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTED POSITION ON THE
BILL- I THINK THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE A GOOD
JOB. OF A LENGTH OF ELABORATING
ON SOME OF THE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL- OF COURSE WE WANT THE
HIGHEST LABOR STANDARDS IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE CREATE. GREEN
INDUSTRY WE ALSO CREATE.
EXCELLENT JOBS AND PATH TO
PROSPERITY FOR PEOPLE FOR
WORKERS AND TO ENCOURAGE
MANUFACTURING TO BE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AT THE SAME TIME WE
DON'T WANT TO HINGED OUR
RENEWALS- HOW DO WE MET AND
JEOPARDIZING OUR ABILITY TO
GET. ELECTRIC TRACKS OUT INTO
THE FIELD I WE DON'T WANT TO
JEOPARDIZE THOSE INCENTIVES IN
AND LEAVE I TO WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE INCENTIVES FOR WHAT RIGHT
NOW IS A VERY RISKY AND
EXPENSIVE PROPOSITION- FOR-
COMPANIES AND INDIVIDUALS- SO
FINDING THAT RIGHT BALANCE OF
MAKING SURE THAT WE DO HAVE THE
INCENTIVES OUT TO MARKET. AND
THAT WE HAVE A PATH TO. THIS
JUST TRANSITION THAT TRULY.
ACHIEVABLE SO HAVING GOOD GOALS.
ALL A REALISTIC IN THE HOLDING
FOR YOU TO OUR MENU. TO BUT NOT.
JEOPARDIZING OUR ABILITY TO-
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO BUY
THESE- THESE NEWER VEHICLES IS
ALSO IMPORTANT. SO WITH THAT
I'M REALLY HAPPY THAT YOU- TOOK
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS- THE
WHOLE RANGE OF CONCERNS IT'S
JUST TO BUT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KNOW HOW. MUCH WORK WAS
DONE ON THIS. YOU TOOK-
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDED AN
APPEALS PROCESS FOR VIOLATIONS
THAT AND A PATHWAY BACK INTO
COMPLIANCE FOR ENTITIES THAT
FALL OUT OF COMPLIANCE. THAT
MODIFIED REPAYMENT PROVISIONS
TO MORE CLOSELY ALIGN WITH THE
PERIOD OF NON COMPLIANCE. AND
HAVE HORRIBLE EXAMINE THE
FEASIBILITY OF DOMESTIC CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS NOW. IS GONNA BE
MORE WORK ON THIS BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL WORKING ON THE LANGUAGE.
AND I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION IS
MOVED. TO OUR HOUSE AND FOR THE
SENATE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE- IS WHERE IT NEEDS TO
BE AND HOPEFULLY THAT WILL ALSO
BE IN THE SUPPORT OF THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE. I THINK
REALLY. GOING OUT ON A LIMB
TODAY- TO SUPPORT THIS AND
REALLY WANT TO SEE IT SUCCEED
AS WE ALL DO AND AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS TO BRING THIS FORWARD. I
DID WE HAVE A MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE IT AND WE HAVE A
SECOND. SO THE- MOTION IS A
SUPPORT AS AMENDED. WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE MACCOLL'S. I'M
SORRY. SHE HAS TO CLOSE I CAN'T
HEAR YOU SHE HAS THE CLOTHES
I'M SORRY YES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YEAH SORRY. THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
ALL THE MEMBERS FOR YOUR VERY
ROBUST CONVERSATION TODAY. I
WANTED TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THIS IS A NEW SPACE FOR ALL OF
US. AS WE TRY TO FIGURE THIS
OUT WE'RE ONLY GOING TO GET IT
DONE IF WE ARE TRULY WORKING
TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE. THE GOALS
THAT THE STATE HAS AS WELL AS
THE GOALS THAT WE ALL HAVE TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS- SO I AM OPEN TO THE
CONVERSATION I'M OPEN TO
CONTINUING TO FIND A RESOLUTION
TO MANUFACTURING I WANT
CALIFORNIA'S STRONG CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING JOBS. JUST LIKE
WHAT I WANT TO SEE THAT ACROSS
THE NATION AS WE TRULY TRULY
WORK ON A JUST TRANSITION AND-
AND THE TRANSPORTATION
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT. AS
CONSUMERS WE HAVE MORE OPTIONS
FOR EV'S BUT ALSO AS JUST
RESIDENTS OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT
ANY TRUCKS THAT ARE THAT ARE
GOING. IN AND OUT OF CALIFORNIA
AS WE REALLY ARE THE CRADLE IN
WHICH THE REST OF THE NATION
RETRIEVED- GOODS AND SERVICES
AND THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES AND
IN THE PORT OF LONG BEACH. THAT
THOSE WORKERS ALSO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
INCENTIVIZE THE BUYING OF
CLEANER. GREENER MORE JUST
TRANSITIONAL CLIMATE CHANGE
ORIENTED VEHICLES TO ENSURE
THAT WE ACTUALLY GET TO WHERE
WE NEED TO GO- AND SO WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF A LOT OF WORK ON
THIS BILL AND I HOPE TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO. TO WORK ON IT
TO GET IT RIGHT- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I WILL THINK MANAGER. THINK.
YOU'VE MADE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS DEEP AS A MAN TO
PER. FREE HI FREE. I FOR NO
BERMAN. BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM NO DALY DALY HI
DAVIES DAVIES NO GIPSON. KALRA
KALRA HI LEE. THREE I MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I
WENT. WHEN NO O'DONNELL. DONALD
I WARD WARD I WICKS WICKS HI.
CURRENT VOTE TEN FOR TEN TO
FOUR WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE ROLE. FOR
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE. WE HAVE
TO HAVE A MOTION. A MOTION AND
A SECOND MOVE ROLL CALL PLEASE
OKAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FOR NOT
VOTING FONG NOT VOTING BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
NOT VOTING DALY DALY AYE DAVIES.
DAVIES NOT VOTING GIPSON. KALRA
KALRA I LEE LEE I MEDINA MEDINA
I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I WENT.
WHEN NOT VOTING O'DONNELL
DONALD I WARD. WARD I WICKS
WICKS I. KERBAL TEN ZERO ZERO
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR UP TO
MEMBERS CAN BE MOVED TO THE
CONSENT ITEMS PLEASE CAN'T
ITEMS ON CONSENT FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG I BERMAN.
I AM FINE CONSENT. BERMAN HI
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON
KALRA KALRA KILEY. LI HI MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN THIS AREA AND
I WENT. WHEN I- DONALD. WARD
WARD I WICKS WICKS HI. RIGHT.
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO
OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED OF NEXT WILL HAVE AB
NINE SEVENTY ONE MR GRAY YOU
MAY PROCEED SENATOR READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
KNOW WE'VE GOT SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES HERE TO PRESENT
BILLS IN THE COMMITTEE GOT A
LATER START THAN ANTICIPATED SO
I WILL ATTEMPT TO BE BRIEF. AB
NINE SEVENTY ONE ALLOWS AN
APPLICANT TO VOLUNTARILY
INCLUDE A SYMBOL ON THEIR ID
CARD OR DRIVER'S LICENSE WHICH
INDICATES THEY LIVE WITH
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY THAT MAY HINDER
THEIR ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT. I HAVE
WITH ME- THIS AFTERNOON A
WITNESS FROM MY DISTRICT A
CONSTITUENT. ASTRID ENGINEER
WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF UT DONE YOU ASK ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY YOU
MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH ASTRID- TO
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS AND
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THE MOST
AS THE WITNESS ON THE LINE. I'M
SORRY MANAGER IS THE WAY ON THE
FOR LINE OR- OKAY OPERATOR FROM
THE PLEASE. THE PHONE FOR THE
WAY FROM. SEVEN ONE. AND YOUR
LINE IS WITH AHEAD. I THANK YOU
FOR MUCH MA'AM CHAIR AND THEN
NUMBER OF MEETING- PRAYER TIME
FOR I'M VERY AND- STILL EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY. YES MY NAME IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO GO I AM THE
VICE PRESIDENT AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY SAID AS THE U. D.
W. WILL REPRESENT A HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND HOME CARE PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
AND DISABLED IN OUR COMMUNITY
BUT FIRST AND FOREMOST I AM A
MOTHER OF A DISABLED ADULT
AUTISTIC. CHILD WHO ALSO HAS A.
WHAT DIDN'T AND- HIS NAME IS
MANUAL MY KNOWN HIM AS AND HE
IS THE PREPARING TO BUT- WHICH
COMES WITH A MORE OF. ABILITY
TO. THINGS SUCH AS HE IS NUMBER
BUT VERY BOTH HERE'S HOW TO BE
IS THE NOT CALL VERBAL. WE.
MEANWHILE HE LOOKS AND HAS THE
STRENGTH OF A YOUNG MAN HE'S
VERY UCH HIGHLIGHTS AND THINGS
WITH HIS BASIC HUMAN INSTINCTS
TOLD FIGHTER FLIGHT TYPE OF
ANYTHING AND FOR THESE VERY
REASONS I AM ALWAYS WORRIED
ABOUT HOW LONG FOR SPIN OFF
THERE IS THERE ANY FIRST
RESPONDER FOR THAT NEXT WEEK IN
REACT TO HIM SHOULD HE EVER
WANDER OFF OR IF HE'S OUT WITH
HIS DAY GROUP AND THERE IS AN
ISSUE THAT MAY BE A POLICE
OFFICER EMT IS CALLED UPON- I
HAVE HEARD AND READ AND SEEN
TOO MANY OF STORY THAT SAID HI
I BILLION ALLOW MY. SON TO BE
ONE OF THOSE MANY STORIES. AND
MANY OF OUR- UPPER FROM TO. THE
ARE OFTEN UNDER. AND OUR
BEHAVIORS ACTIONS OR LACK OF
ACTION MAY COME ACROSS. AS
BEING DEFIANT OR DRUG INDUCED
WHEN IN FACT IT IS PART OF
THEIR DISABILITY OR LACK OF THE
PROPER MEDICATION. AND THIS IS
THE REASON WHY I'M- HERE AT MY
UNION SUPPORT- MY CRAZY IDEAS
SUCH AS HESE. AND I HAVE SET
OUT TO FIND LIKE MINDED
INDIVIDUALS LIKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRING ANOTHER.
ORGANIZATION AND LEGISLATORS AS
YOURSELF. THAT BELIEVED THAT
THERE WAS A BETTER WAY TO
EDUCATE TRAIN CREATE BETTER
ALERT SYSTEMS AND TOOLS. THAT
WILL HELP I'M NOT GOING TO HAVE
TO ANSWER. TO FINISH UP YOUR
YOUR TIME. IS UP IF YOU CAN
JUST FINISH UP OKAY. OKAY AND
EIGHTY SEVEN NINE ONE PROVIDE
FAMILY THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED
TO ENSURE PAPER INTERACTION AND
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION A AND- JUST
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I HAVE
NO OPPOSITION REGISTERED- I.
DON'T SEE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
FOR ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL. IS THERE ANYONE THE
WITNESS ROOM OKAY OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OF AB NINE
SEVENTY ONE. AND LET ME KNOW IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO REVISED
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
NINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AT THE TIME WE DO
HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN THE QUEUE.
START WITH NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
PROVISIONAL AUTHORISATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO
IN SUPPORT. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MADISON BISCOP WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT SERVER
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THERESA ANDERSON WITH
THE ARK AND UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT. AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWO
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MELISSA CORTES REPRESENTING
AUTISM SPEAKS IN SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MANAGER THANK YOU OPERATOR I'LL
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE
IF ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE MR GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT BILL VERY HAPPY TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT TODAY. I
THINK IT'LL BE VERYMEANINGFUL
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE I WITH THAT
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL. I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERSHIP FAST RELIABLE.
THANK YOU CAN WE OPEN A- ROLL
CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN HI FONG.
FONG I BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I DAILY
DAILY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GIPSON KALRA KALRA I LEAVE LEE
I MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN.
WHEN WHAT A WIN I HAVE A DONALD.
WARD WARD I WICKS WICKS HI.
THREE RIGHT- TWELVE TWELVE ZERO
THANK YOU THE BILL IS NOT LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE YOU
ARE HERE FOR EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY
AND YOU MAY RECEIVE ONE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ON A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
THE BETTER PART OF FOUR YEARS.
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY THE SAFE
STREETS ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU I'LL MAKE THIS
SHORT I WANT TO OF COURSE THANK
THE CHEERING YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER DILIGENT WORKING OR
DELETE YOUR DEEP COLLABORATION
ON THIS BILL WITH MY STAFF AND
OUR COALITION. EVERY YEAR I
ATTEND A MEMORIAL FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS KILLED IN HIGH
SPEED COLLISIONS. EVERY YEAR
FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS OVER A
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAVE DIED
IN SPEED RELATED CRASHES. WITH
TENS OF THOUSANDS MORE SEVERELY
INJURED. AND EVERY YEAR THESE
HUMAN TRAGEDIES MAKE LESS AND
LESS SENSE BECAUSE THIS IS
ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE. THERE'S A
TESTED WIDELY USED TECHNOLOGY
THAT CAN PREVENT THESE INJURIES
AND DEATHS. THE TOOL USED
EFFECTIVELY BY OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY CITIES AND SIXTEEN STATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY. MULTIPLE
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT SPEED
SAFETY SYSTEMS CAN LEAD TO
DRAMATIC IMPROVEMENTS ON SAFE
LOCATIONS. REDUCING SPEEDING BY
AS MUCH AS SIXTY FIVE PERCENT.
SERIOUS INJURIES IN FATAL
CRASHES BY UP 258% THIS BILL
WILLALLOW FIVE CITIES IN THE
STATE TO PILOT THIS PROVEN
SAFETY TOOL IN SENSITIVE AREAS
AROUND VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
LIKE SCHOOLS AND SENIOR CENTERS
AND ON EACH CITY'S HIGH INJURY
NETWORK. WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
BUILDING INTO THE LEGISLATION
SIGNIFICAN PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
EQUITY PROVISIONS FOR LOW
INCOME DRIVERS AND DUE PROCESS.
TO ADDRESS EQUITY. CITATIONS
UNDER THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
CIVIL NOT CRIMINAL WILL NOT
RESULT IN ANY POINTS ON A
DRIVER'S RECORD. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CITATIONS WILL BE
CAPPED AT FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON THE LEVEL
OF SPEEDING. CITIES WILL NEED
TO OFFER DIVERSION PROGRAM AND
COMMUNITY SERVICE FOR FOLKS WHO
CAN'T PAY. TO ADDRESS PRIVACY
THE BILL FORBIDS FACIAL
RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY AND
DRIVER PHOTOS BEING TAKEN BY
SYSTEM. DATA CAN BE ACCESSED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR FOR ANY
PURPOSE EXCEPT FOR THIS PILOT
AND DATA MUST BE DESTROYED BY
DATE SPECIFIED IN THE BILL. TO
ADDRESS THE PROCESS CITATIONS
WILL ONLY BE ISSUED TO DRIVERS
TRAVELING AT LEAST ELEVEN MILES
ABOVE THE SPEED LIMIT. CITIES
MUST CLEARLY SIGN POST SENATORS
TO IDENTIFY THE PRESENCE OF A
SYSTEM CAN ONLY ISSUE WARNING
NOTICES AT THE BEGINNING OF A
PILOT. AND HAVE TO PROVIDE AN
APPEALS PROCESS. SB SAFETY
SYSTEM CAN'T BE OPERATED BEYOND
THE FIRST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
UNLESS SPECIFIC SPEED
REDUCTIONS ARE MET. I WANT TO
THANK REPRESENTATIVES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR ENGAGE IN DEEP
DISCUSSIONS ON AMENDMENTS
REFLECTED IN THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS THAT HAVE BROUGHT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROL. AND PARK TO
NEUTRAL. WE'RE ALSO IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
TEAMSTERS AND ARE COMMITTED TO
REACHING A POSITIVE RESOLUTION
THAT WORKS FOR ALL PARTIES.
THIS POLICY IS ABOUT SAVING
LIVES AND IMPROVING THE SAFETY
OF SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CONSTITUENTS. ARE CHILDREN
GOING TO SCHOOL. BICYCLISTS
HEADING TO WORK SENIORS DOING
ERRANDS. WE MUST REMEMBER THOSE
WE HAVE LOST BUT ALSO TAKE
ACTION TO PROTECT PEOPLE WE
KNOW WE CAN SAVE. AB FIVE FIFTY
IS A STEP IN THAT DIRECTION.
AND WITHOUTTESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY ARGENTI YOU. A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF BAY AREA
FAMILIES FOR SAFE STREETS AND
SELENA RENTALS THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONES I
THINK WE'LL HEAR FROM FROM
JENNY FIRST OPERATOR WE LEFT
ALLOW- OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
BOTH OF THE WITNESSES BUT- WILL
IT JENNY GO FIRST AND THEN.
LEADER RUNNELS OPPOSING. MY
NAME IS JENNY YOU TEN YEARS AGO
MY MOTHER WAS CROSSING THE
STREET WHAT A SPEEDING SPEEDING
DRIVER HIT HER. EVERYTHING THAT
THE FACTOR DAILY LIFE AND
HAPPINESS AND IN THAT MOMENT.
MEETING DRIVER LEFT MY BAG YOUR
MOM WITH THE RAPTORS CLEAN
FACTORED RICH AND A FRACTURED
HUMERUS. MEETING DRIVER OFF
LEFT MY MOM A WIFE MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER IMPROPERLY TURNER
WHAT OTHER INJURIES THAT WILL
NEVER HEAL. INTERGRAPH MY MOM
SUFFERS FROM SEVERE COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT SYMPTOMS EXTREME
STAGES OF ALZHEIMER'S SEVERE
DEPRESSION. SEVERE
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
INTERTITLE TNDENCIES. BRENT
HIGHER DECADE NOW MY MONTHLY
THE REALITY IS FAR FROM WHAT
MANY THE STATE IS LIVING. MY
SIBLINGS AND I HAVE A HEART
BROKEN AGAIN AND AGAIN I WOULD
TAKE CARE OF HER DALY. WE TRY
TO HOLD ON TO THE GOOD MEMORIES
EVEN AS HE LASHES OUT AT US.
BUT WE CAN CONTROL DELETE A
WORST. PRACTICE LIKE THE ONE
THAT DESTROYED OUR FAMILY ARE
PREVENTABLE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JIM BY THE LEGISLATION EIGHTY
FIVE FIFTY IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. WE HAVE TO START TO
ADDRESS THE DEVASTATING TOLL
SPEED. AND TAKING IN OUR CITY.
NOT IN TERMS OF ABOUT THE SPEED
RELATED DEATHS EACH YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TO REALLY
INJURED AS WELL. SHE FIFTY
SYSTEMS CAN PREVENT SO MANY
DEATHS. IN SO MUCH SUFFERING WE
NEED A POWERFUL TOOL AND WE
NEED IT URGENTLY. I HAVE
FOUNDING MEMBER OF SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA FAMILIES FOR
SAFE STREETS A GROUP OF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
TRAFFIC CRASHES. AND ASKING
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MEMBER
TO PLEASE SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY. EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY WILL
SAVE LIVES AND PREVENT. MORE
TRAGEDIES FROM DANGEROUS
BEATING. THANK NEXT PLEASE. I
CAN'T REMEMBER STILL LEADER
CHEN MANAGER OF THE LAST TO OF
AND SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY I SPOKE
LAST WEEK TO THE ABOUT THE
DANGERS SPEEDING AND EFFORT
WITH- ONLY SEEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC THIS BEARS REPEATING
AND SUBSIDIES ARE AFFORDED
EVERY TOOL AVAILABLE TO PUT AN
END TO THE UNNECESSARY DEATHS
CAUSED BY TRAFFIC CRASHES ON
OUR STREETS. NEARLY FOUR
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS DYING
CRASHES EACH YEAR AND MORE THAN
THREE TIMES THAT AMOUNT OR
SEVERELY INJURED TRAFFICKED UP
IN LOS ANGELES ARE UP 55% IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MANY DUE TO
MOTORISTS DRIVING WELL ABOVE
THE POSTED SPEED LIMIT THE
SERIOUS INJURIES AND DEATHS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE AMONG. LOW
INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR CHILDREN
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WALKING
SPEED KILLS AND IT ROB THEIR
COMMUNITIES OF SECURITY AND
VITALITY THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AIMS TO ELIMINATE
TRAFFIC DEATHS WE LEAVE WITH
ENGINEERING STREET DESIGN AND
EDUCATION BUT ELIMINATING
TRAFFIC FATALITIES REQUIRES A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH ENSURING
SAFETY ON OUR STREETS MEANS
HOLDING RECKLESS DRIVERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA NEED
THE MOST EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE TO IMPROVE SAFETY FOR
EVERYONE. BY PROVIDING RELIABLE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR DRIVING WELL
ABOVE THE SPEED LIMIT SPEED
SAFETY SYSTEMS ARE PROVEN TO
LOWER THE INCIDENCE OF SPEEDING
AND REDUCE SEVERE INJURIES AND
DEATHS BY UP 258% EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY WOULD ALLOW CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THE PILOT SPEED
SAFETY SYSTEMS ON THEIR STREETS
TO FURTHER REDUCE SPEEDING AND
IMPROVE SAFETY FOR EVERYONE WE
ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND SHARE
FRIEDMAN HAVE PUT INTO CRAFTING
THIS BILL TO AUTHORIZE PILOTED
AND PROTECT PRIVACY. ENSURE
EQUITY IN DEPLOYMENT REDUCE THE
LEGAL PENALTY OF CITATION AND
PROVIDE LOW INCOME PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS NOT ABUSED IT
ALSO REQUIRES CITIES TO INVEST
REVENUE IMPROVING SAFE STREET
DESIGNED FOR THEIR RESIDENTS
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY WILL IMPROVE
OUR COMMUNITIES AND SAVE LIVES.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE-
TWO WITNESSES IN OFFICE. FOR
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE BEAVER.
FOLLOWED BY SHANE GOT OPERATOR
YOU COULD PLEASE BRING THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. HELLO MY
NAME. YES HELLO HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHEAPER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SAFER
STREETS LA ALTHOUGH EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY IS WELL INTENDED THE BILL
STILL HAS SIGNIFICANT FLAWS
WHICH NEED TO BE CORRECTED WELL
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
WE HAVE NOT YET RECEIVED
SUFFICIENT COMMITMENTS TO ALLOW
US TO MOVE OUR OPPOSITION WE
FEEL THE FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS
ARE NECESSARY TO MAKE THIS A
SUCCESSFUL AND EQUITABLE PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WILL ENCOURAGE
PUBLIC ACCEPTANCE. A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM PROHIBITION AGAINST
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ADDING ANY
ADDITIONAL FEES ON TO THE STATE
IS FINE AMOUNTS INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO LATE PAYMENT
FEES AND HEARING SCREENS A
PROHIBITION AGAINST BOOTING
TOWING ARE HOLDING THE VEHICLE
REGISTRATION RENEWAL FOR NON
PAYMENT SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT
THE BASIC SPEED LAW AND SPEECH
TRAP PROTECTIONS APPLY TO
CAMERA ISSUE TICKETS SIMILAR TO
POLICE ISSUE TICKETS LIMITING
THE USE OF CAMERAS TO ENFORCE
SPEED LIMITS IN SCHOOL ZONES
THE TIMES. AND DISTANCES
CURRENTLY IN STATE LAW. WHY
MAKE IT WORSE. CAMERAS ARE USED
TO FOR SCHOOL SPEED SCHOOL ZONE
SPEED LIMITS. THE SPEED LIMIT
EXT MILES PER HOUR WHEN
FLASHING SIGN BE USED WITHOUT
SUCH SIGNAGE MOTORISTS ARE LEFT
WONDERING IF AND WHEN THE
SCHOOL SPEED LIMIT IS IN EFFECT
ARE CAUGHT IN A GOTCHA
SITUATION. THAT A WARNING
NOTICE BE ISSUED FOR THE FIRST
VIOLATION UP TO TWENTY MILES
PER HOUR OVER THE SPEED LIMIT.
WE FEEL THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS NEED TO BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE ON A
MONTHLY BASIS DATA ON THE
NUMBER OF VIOLATIONS CAPTURED
AT EACH SPEED IMPROVEMENT
NUMBER WARNING NOTICES. AND
TICKETS TICKETS ISSUED NUMBER
OF REPEAT OFFENDERS AND THE
DISPOSITION OF EACH CASE ALL
THE NEWS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CAPTURE AND REPORT THIS DATA
WHICH IS SIMILAR TO THE DATE WE
RECEIVE PROMOTION RESTRICTIONS.
USING READ LIKE TAX FURTHER WE
BELIEVE ANY EVALUATION OF THE
SYSTEM'S EFFECTIVENESS BE DONE
BY AN INDEPENDENT PARTY NOT THE
JURISDICTION RUNNING THE
PROGRAM AT THIS AT THIS
CONSTITUTES A CONFLICT BEST.
INTEREST FINALLY WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THE CURRENT
AUTHORIZATION OF THE USE OF
REVENUE GENERATED BY THE
PROGRAM STILL PROVIDES AN
INCENTIVE FOR CITIES TO RUN THE
SYSTEM WITH THE PROFIT MOTIVE.
WE BELIEVE ALL EXCESS REVENUE
BEYOND THE ACTUAL COST OF
BILLIONS. OF COULD FINISH UP
DOING BUT- YOU CAN FINISH UP
PLEASE FINISHING UP TO FIND.
YEAH THANK YOU IN ACCESSIBLE TO
LOCAL. JURISDICTION RUNNING THE
PROGRAM. WE THANK YOU FOR THE
ARE. TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
ON THE IMPORTANT. THANK YOU
MISTER GUSMAN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON SHANE DAWSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALIFORNIA NOT COMMITTED
TRANSIT IN. BOTH OF THESE
UNIONS ARE OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
FIVE FIFTY. BUT I WOULD SAY WE
ARE VERY HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
WORK OUT OUR DIFFERENCES WITH
THE AUTHOR. WE HAVE HAD
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS AND I
THINK WE'LL GET THERE. JUST
VERY QUICKLY FOR THE UNIONS THE
ROADS ARE THEIR WORKPLACE A
MAJORITY OF THEIR MEMBERS. AS
SUCH WE SHARE THE AUTHOR'S
DESIRE TO CREATE SAFER STREETS
FOR EVERYONE HOWEVER WE ALSO
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
POLICIES WE CHOOSE TO ACHIEVE
SICKENING ARE DESIGNED TO DO
THAT WITH MINIMAL NEGATIVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. WE
NEED TO ENSURE FAIRNESS WITH
PARTICULAR KNOWLEDGE THAT THESE
PROPOSALS ELIMINATE SOME VERY
IMPORTANT DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS THAT DRIVERS
CURRENTLY ENJOY. AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
PEOPLE. WORKING HARD TO MAKE
ENDS MEET. ACTUALLY I DON'T
THINK WE'RE THERE YET. BUT IT'S
OUR HOPE THAT WORKING WITH THE
OSCAR SUPPORTERS WE WILL GET
BACK THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NOW WILL MOVE TO. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION I SEE
ONE SPEAKER IN THE CHAMBERS
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR. A
MANAGER MEMBERS CHRIS MCCABE
LIED ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK WITH ANYONE IN THE
WITNESS ROOM. NOPE OKAY
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF AB. FIVE FIFTY.
N. LANE JIM IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
FIVE FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YEAH ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB. FIVE FIFTY.
AND AT THIS TIME WE DO ABOUT
THIRTY SIX IN OUR QUEUE. AND
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ONLY
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES AND ON BEHALF OF
THE DIFFERENT CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS BOTH IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
ENSURE. FRIEDMAN FOR THEIR WORK
ON THE BILL THANK YOU. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER TWO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET
AFTERNOON TO STEVE ALL COMING
ON MEDICAID TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT OF IT
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY THANK YOU.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES NAY
KALO DELUCA ON BEHALF OF THE
OAKLAND MAYOR AND THE OAKLAND
CITY COUNCIL PROUD TO BE CO
SPONSORS ARE REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND
THE CHAIRWOMAN. NEXUS NUMBER
TWO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AND-
GOOD AFTERNOON BENEFITING BALIK
WE HAVE WITH THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY
THANK YOU. NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JOSHUA
SHOT FOR THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR LONDON BREED ALSO PLEASED
TO BE A CO SPONSOR AND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT TO
NUMBER TWO OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KATE GREEN REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. WHEN I GO TO NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M AN INTERN
MEMBERS REMAIN A CARBOXYL
ELLIOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE NUMBER THREE
OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GO TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OF THE
NUMBER TO FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS HALEY CAREER
REPRESENTING TRANSFORM AND
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIDE.
FIFTY NEXT TO BE NUMBER TWO
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS AGO I HAD.
OKAY SASHA PERIGO ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY
SORRY FIVE FIFTY THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS KAT SINI RESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NUMBER NUMBER SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JULIE NICHOLSON I'M A RECENT
SURVIVOR OF A TRAFFIC CRASH IN
FRANCISCO REPRESENTING FAMILIES
FOR SAFE STREETS STRONGLY
SUPPORT. EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY. I'M
GONNA NUMBER SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS HEIDI
PETERSON I'M A RESIDENT OF
TAMPA TO GO MY GRAND GREAT
GRAND MOTHER WAS KILLED IN A
TRAFFIC CRASH AND I HAVE BEEN A
VICTIM OF. A TRAFFIC CRASH
ACCIDENT MYSELF. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY. NEXT
TO THE NUMBER TWO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CARPARK FROM APPALACHIAN
STATE'S TRUCKING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. NOT GOING TO NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DEVELOP VANDER ON BEHALF
OF THE RICHMOND FAMILY
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY THANK YOU. NEXUS NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON J. C.
COHEN REPRESENTING THE ARK SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS PATRICK
TOPPER CALLING RESIDENT IN THE
AREA I GREW UP IN A FAMILY IN
LOS ANGELES I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. WELL
NOW GONNA NUMBER TWO OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS YURIY DANSE I'M A
RESIDENT SEVERANCE OF SCHOOL
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
MOTORISTS ASSOCIATION- WOULD
LIKE TO VOICE STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB FIVE FIVE ZERO THANK YOU.
I'M NOT GONNA LINE ONE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TOM WENT FOR A
WALK BIKE BERKELEY AND IN HONOR
OF MY FRIENDS MAKING JACQUI WHO
WERE HIT BY SPEEDING CARS IN
SEPARATE CRASHES WHILE RIDING
THEIR BIKES IN SUPPORT. NEXT IS
NUMBER ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JODY MAJERUS ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WALK SAN
FRANCISCO AND ON BEHALF OF MY
ORGANIZATION THE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FIVE FIFTY THANK YOU.
WHEN I GO TO NUMBER TWO FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS GENEVA HESSLER REPRESENTING
THE BARBARY COAST NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION IN SAN FRANCISCO
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
TO ME NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS GERRY GUIDELINES I
AM REPRESENTING FAMILIES FOR
SAFE STREETS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONOR LYNCH
FOUNDATION MY SON CONNOR WAS
SIXTEEN WHEN HE LOST HIS LIFE
AND HE WAS KILLED BY SPEEDING
CAR AND TRANSLATE TO PORT.
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY. THE
DISTRICT. NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY
SURE- MY NAME IS JEAN ON THE
BLOCK AND I'M FROM SAN JOSE-
I'M A MEMBER
FAMILY FOR STATE STREET AND I'M
ALSO VERY MOTHER LOCKED BY
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD SON TO THE
BEST IN CLASS AND I TOTALLY
SUPPORT. EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY
THANK YOU. WHEN I GOT IN LINE
THREE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI RACHEL FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BICYCLE COALITION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY. NEXUS NUMBER TWO NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS JEAN WALSH I'M AN
OAKLAND RESIDENT MY ROOMMATE'S
MOTHER WAS KILLED IN A CAR
CRASH AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY THANK YOU.
NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DD
GONZALEZ I'M A MEMBER OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
FOR SAFE STREETS. AND ALSO A
SURVIVOR OF THE NEAR FATAL
CRASH I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
FIVE FIFTY. NEXUS NUMBER TWO
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOE FOX I'M
REPRESENTING SAN FRANCISCO'S
INDIA BASIN NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
TWO OH FOUR THESE GUYS HAD. MY
NAME IS CODY GILLIS I REPRESENT
THEM FOR STATE STREET. MY FIVE
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER DAUGHTER
EILEEN OSTER LINE WHEN SHE WAS
HIT BY A SPEEDING CAR I STRONG
SUPPORT AB. FIVE FIFTY. WELL
NOW GO TO LINE ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS A NEED TO HE GO REPRESENT
FAMILIES FOR SAFE STREETS I'M
ALSO THE FOUNDER TO BREAKING
KILL MOTHER CALLING HE NOW
NOTHING LESS WHO TO TALK TO YOU
A FEW QUESTIONS I STRONGLY
SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER
TWO NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SUSAN WEISBERG ON
THE SENIOR RESIDENTS OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB SIDE. FIFTY WE NOW
GO TO LINE ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BORN HAMMER OF
TANGIBLE RESIDENTS AND VICTIMS
OF TRAFFIC VIOLENCE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF KEEPSAKES FF IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AS CHAIR OVER ME SAN
FRANCISCO PEDESTRIAN RACING CAR
DEPENDENT SAN GABRIEL VALLEY I
VOTED FOR A FAMILY MEMBER CHU
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS BILL
AB. FIVE FIFTY. NOT GONNA LINE
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH CALLING HELLO
AND I'M THE RECENT SURVIVOR OF
A SPEED RELATED TRAFFIC CRASH I
REPRESENTS SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA FAMILY FOR STATE STREET
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIVE FIFTY. THANK YOU. THANKS-IS NUMBER ONE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
GRANDMA BEVERLY AND I LOVE MY
FIRSTBORN GRANDSON IN BERKELEY
ONE CLASS- I'M ALSO RETIRED-
CALIFORNIA WALKS TOWARD MEMBER
AND I HELPED CO FOUND SOCAL
FAMILY SIX BAYSTREET AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY I'M NOT A NOT. A PEOPLE
ARE DYING ON OUR STREETS THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVED TO NUMBER ONE OH
EIGHT ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M RICHARD GIRLING OF
SAN FRANCISCO I'M A MEMBER OF
WALK SAN FRANCISCO AND FAMILIES
FOR SAFE STREETS BOTH OF WHICH
I JOIN DUE TO THE FACT THAT IT
WAS ALMOST KILLED BY BEING RUN
OVER BY A BUS. IN ON SIX
SENTENCES BECAUSE ST I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FIVE FIVE BELOW.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
YOUR CLOSED OFF FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE TENDERLOIN COMMUNITY
BENEFIT DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTY THANK
YOU. NEXUS NUMBER ONE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS STATE CALARE I REPRESENT
FAMILIES FOR STATE STREET MY
WIFE WAS RECENTLY FOR THE
INJURED IN A CAR CRASH THAT
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE
FIFTY. NOW READ A NUMBER TWO OH
EIGHT ZERO HEAD. UHHUH. TWO
AIRLINE IS OPEN. HELLO TWO
NUMBER- TO NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
YOU FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BIMOLECULAR BARNARD AND I. BYE
BECKEL COALITION WE HAVE THE
SIMPSONS BUT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBER
DAVID YOU. HAVE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY.
HELLO GOT A LINE TWO NINE SIX.
THESE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
GINA I WASN'T SECOND CISCO AND
I SUPPORT. EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU. ON THE OTHER LINE TO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE PROPOSAL I
TWO HUNDRED LINES OPEN. HELLO
WHEN I SAID THEY'VE GOT YES MY
NAME IS SPEND ALL DOYLE AND I
AM A SURVIVOR OF TROUBLED BY
WAS CRASHING NO I'M
REPRESENTING. THE BAY AREA
FAMILY FOR STATE STREET AND
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT FOR THIS.
BILL FIVE FIFTY THANK YOUNG.
COOPER USUALLY ONE OF THE LAW
OPEN GETTING FOR. SOUNDS LIKE
MY PREVIOUS LAW. JUST A MOMENT
HERE. THAT'S BETTER THANK YOU
CAN CONTINUE. CORRECT NEXT TO
BE LINED ONE A ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JAMES JONES I
REPRESENT UP SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES FOR STATE
STREET. I AM A SURVIVOR OF A
TRAFFIC CRASH BUT WITH
PERMANENT BRAIN AND SPINAL
DAMAGE. I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FIVE FIFTY THANK YOU. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER THREE OH FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MEGAN G. I AM A RESIDENT OF THE
BAYVIEW AND SAN FRANCISCO ALSO
A WALK SAN FRANCISCO COURT
MEMBER. I'M A TRANSPORTATION
PLANNER REGIONALLY FROM
AUSTRALIA WHERE I CAN TELL YOU
THAT SOME OF THE PROGRAM EIGHTY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT RIGHT NO TALK
ABOUT OVERLY FOLKS WE'RE NOT
TAKING ANY MORE TESTIMONY
PLEASE JUST YOUR NAME ANY
ORGANIZATION AND WHAT DO YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
WITH A LOT OF OTHER BILLS ON
THE DOCKET TODAY APOLOGIES
THAT'S OKAY. I APOLOGIZE SIR.
OKAY ASSEMBLY EIGHTY FIFTY.
THANK YOU PERFECT. NEXT TO BE
NUMBER THREE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING I'M
JACQUELINE TEN I'M WALK EXCEPT
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTY
THANK YOU. NOW GO TO LINE THREE
OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
THREE OH SIX EUROPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY HI- MY NAME IS RYAN
ON MOTOR SHOW ME I LIVE IN OAK
GROVE CALIFORNIA I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTY. THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER THREE OH
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ON THAT SIDE MEET AS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF FREMONT IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS WELL AS
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BERKELEY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER
THREE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JONATHAN CAST
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SPUR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTY.
WELL NOW MOVES THE LINE THREE
OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS- CHARLES SHAPING- ARE
REPRESENTING THE SAN FRANCISCO
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE I'M CALLING IN TO
VOICE MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXUS NUMBERS THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS LEE SJ HOLM
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
VISION ZERO NETWORK AND I'M
BASED IN SONOMA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FIFTY.
AND NEXT WILL BE NUMBER TWO
NINETY EIGHT. TO NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES THIS IS
MATTHEW STAFFORD FROM SAN
FRANCISCO- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OUT OF. EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY. AND
AT THIS TIME OR NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU I'M GONNA GO
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE CHEN IS
AREA WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- FIRST
AND FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR THE
pHE'S DEMONSTRATED TO THIS ISSUE
AND FOR THE DIFFERENT
ITERATIONS THAT HE'S BROUGHT
FORWARD IN THE PAST I'VE
SUPPORTED THIS WITH THE COPY
OUT THAT I MAY NOT WANT TO
SUPPORTED MOVING FORWARD- I'VE
BASICALLY HAD A VERY
CHALLENGING CHALLENGE DIFFICULT
TIME. BRINGING MYSELF TO
SUPPORT BECAUSE OF- THE
TECHNOLOGY BEING UTILIZED AND
I'VE SPOKEN TO THE AUTHOR AND
HE'S CLARIFIED THAT OBVIOUSLY
HE'S HE'S MADE QUITE A BIT OF
CHANGES AND ALSO THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HE'S TAKEN. MY I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT MY MAIN CHALLENGE
IS THAT I FEEL. PROJECTS
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS. CREATED
DELINEATING LYING BETWEEN THE
HAVES AND THE HAVE NOTS- I
MYSELF HAVE RECEIVED A TICKET.
ALONG THE METRO LINE IN MY
DISTRICT- AND I HATED FULLY
WELL KNOWING THAT HAD I NOT
HATED I WOULDN'T BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT. AND IT FRUSTRATES ME
TO KNOW THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY NOT HAVE THE SAVVY THE
CONNECTIONS THE- MAYBE LEGAL
APTITUDE OR OR KNOWLEDGE- OR OR
HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL TO BE
INFORMED. THAT THEY CAN GET
AWAY WITHOUT PAYING IT. CAN CAN
GET AWAY- BUT THOSE THAT MAY BE
OF LESSER MEANS MORE MODEST
MEANS- WILL NOT QUESTION IT AND
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MAKE EVERY-
ATTEMPT TO PAY IT AND BE GOOD
IN ACCORDANCE TO LAW SO.
BECAUSE OF THAT I JUST HAD A
BIT OF A CHALLENGING TIME BUT I
SO APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'VE DONE
AND ALL THE CHANGES YOU'VE
MADE. THAT HI I'M I'M OF TWO
MINDS I'M TRYING TO LISTEN TO
THE REST OF THE HEARING AND SEE
WHERE I WOULD GO MYSELF BUT I
WOULD WANT TO AT LEAST GET TO A
PLACE WHERE I CAN GIVE YOU THE
<c.green>OURTESY OF BOTH- AND SEE HOW</c>
THIS AND WHAT I ALSO DO
APPRECIATE IS THE FACT THAT
IT'S A FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM.
AND SEE HOW THIS WORKS BUT I
JUST HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT MY
FRUSTRATION HAS BEEN WITH HE
PREVIOUS PROGRAMS AND HOW
pEXTENT. I'M ALMOST VERY MUCH
TEMPTED TO INTRODUCE A BILL.
DEMANDING THAT. ALL THE-
AGENCIES THAT DEPLOYED. CAMERAS
IN THE PAST THAT ERRONEOUSLY.
ASSESSED FEES ON CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS BUT NOT AND DIDN'T
GO AFTER OTHERS. GIVE BACK ALL
OF THOSE FEES NOW WITH INTEREST.
BECAUSE IT'S SO FRUSTRATING TO
SEE THAT WE WOULD DO THAT AND
CREATE A VERY- THREE EIGHT
DELINEATING LINE BETWEEN THOSE
WHO HAVE AND THOSE WHO HAVE
NOT. SO BUT AGAIN I'M GO
VEERING OFF A LITTLE BIT TOO
MUCH OFF OF THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU'VE DONE
AND I'M GONNA LISTEN AND TRY TO
GET TO A PLACE WHERE I CAN
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU MISTER
LEE. I WANT TO THANK OUR
CALLING CONSENSUS COOPER BRING
FOR THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
MEASURE BEFORE US I'M A BIG
BELIEVER THAT WE SHOULD BE
SOLVING OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROBLEMS WITH INFRASTRUCTURE
SOLUTIONS AND I BELIEVE THIS IS
ENTIRELY WHAT IT IS I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR VERY
NEARLY TAILING THIS BILL
PUTTING A LOT OF CONDITIONS IN
IT AND ULTIMATELY- TRUSTING
THAT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING MY CITY CENTRE THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
EFFECTIVELY AND KEEP YOUR SEATS
STREETS SAFE. AS WE HEARD FROM
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY FAR TOO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE OR THEIR LOVED
ONES HAVE HAD FATAL COLLISIONS
HAPPENING AND THIS IS A
SYSTEMIC ISSUE AND I THINK THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
DEPLOY MODERN TECHNOLOGY WE CAN
DRASTICALLY REDUCE THE FATE I
TELL OUTCOMES OF SPEEDING AS
WELL AS EVERYTHING TOO OFTEN
THE FATAL INTERACTIONS OF
POLICE DISCRETION AS WELL FROM
TRAFFIC INCIDENTS SO I THINK
THIS BILL IS GREAT BECAUSE IT
DOES TWO THINGS AT ONE TIME.
AND HOPE THAT MORE COMMUNITIES-
AND MORE CITIES WILL BILL THE
BENEFIT THESE PILOT PROGRAMS
BUT AGAIN I WANT. TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR. ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT- THE FINES ARE NOT TO OVER
BURDENSOME ESPECIALLY FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND I KNOW
THAT. I TRUST THIS AUTHOR TO
KEEP WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT-
YOU KNOW THE BILL THE GOAL THE
BILL. IS TO IS TO HAVE SAFER
STREETS NOT TO PENALIZE PEOPLE.
SO I REALLY DO HOPE THAT THE
AUTHOR CONTINUE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT
BILLS CONTINUE IN THAT SPIRIT.
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO VOTE
FOR TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA THANK YOU I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTONOMY
TRANSMITTANCE HIM- YEAH I KNOW
THAT- WE'VE TALKED A LOT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS ON
THIS BILL I'M NOT GOING TO BE
OUT THERE BUT THE CITY IS SAN
JOSE WHICH IS A STRONG.
PROPONENT OF THE BILL WE HAVE.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
PEDESTRIAN FATALITIES OVER THE
YEARS AND FORTUNATELY I DON'T
THINK THAT THE STAFF REPORT
ANALYSIS OF PROBABLY POINTS OUT
THAT- AUTOMATED SPEED
ENFORCEMENT CAN ABSOLUTELY HAVE
A POSITIVE IMPACT IN TERMS OF
DISCRIMINATIVE DISCRIMINATORY
TRAFFIC STOPS OF BUT THE SAME
TIME THE AREAS WHERE THEY GET
LOCATED ALSO TEND TO BE HIGHER
DENSITY TEND TO BE. THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT ALSO TEND TO
GET- MITIGATED MORE- DO BY
EITHER WAY AND SO I DO
APPRECIATE IS A MOTHER CALLING
FROM SAN JOSE POINTED OUT OF
ALL THE MEASURES THAT ARE TAKEN
TO DEAL WITH ISSUES OF EQUITY
BUT I THINK ULTIMATELY WE KNOW.
THIS PROGRAM AND FOR FIVE YEARS
NOT ALL THE MONEY THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IN INFRASTRUCTURE EVEN
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL LEAD TO TRAFFIC
CALMING MEASURES ON THOSE
CORNERS BECAUSE THAT'S
ULTIMATELY THE LONG TERM
SOLUTION IS SAFER STREETS AND
DOES TRAFFIC CALMING MEASURES
BUT- I DO BELIEVE THAT IN THE
MEANTIME THERE ARE MEASURES
LIKE THESE. THAT CAN SLOW THE
TRAFFIC DOWN AND SAVE LIVES-
AND I THINK THAT ULTIMATELY WE
JUST SEE TO HAVE- SAFER STREETS
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
THE OTHERS PUT INTO IT. AND I
KNOW THAT THE- THE OPPOSITION
WE HEARD FROM OUR PART TO
PRESERVE THE TEAMSTERS- AND AS
THEY INDICATED THAT THEY'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT I'M CONFIDENT THEY'LL BE
RESOLUTION OF THOSE ISSUES AS
WELL AS A THANK. YOU THANK YOU
MISS DAVIS. THANK YOU MR CHIU
QUICK. AMERICA TO THE TWO
SOUTHERN CAL. SO DUE TO WHICH
ONES THOSE ARE. SO WE WANT TO
MAKE THAT WE A CITIES NORTHERN.
AND SOUTHERN- AND THE CITIES OF
SAN FRANCISCO SAN JOSE OAKLAND
HAVE WANTED TO DO THIS-
DIRECTION MANY OTHER CITIES
AROUND THE STATE THEY ARE
INTERESTED LOS ANGELES.
OBVIOUSLY BEING THE LARGEST
CITY IN THE STATE BY A FACTOR
OF MANY- WILL BE PART OF IT THE
FACILITY IS NOT YET BEEN
IDENTIFIED IT'S SOMETHING I'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING WITH- WITH THE
CHAIR OF WHAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE- I SUSPECT WE WILL
WORK THIS OUT- IN THE IN THE
COMING COMMITTEES- BUT- HAPPY
TO. RECEIVE FEEDBACK ON THAT
AND I ALSO WANNA JUST GO
THANKED THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
FOR SUPPORTING THIS BECAUSE
THEY UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
PILOT. AS NECESSARY TO SAVE
LIVES AND- AND OF COME ON
BOARD. IT JUST- A COMMENT THAT
OF ONE OF THE OF WITNESSES TO
PUT OUT THERE I THINK BE GREAT
TO BE ABLE TO SEE THE DATA COME
YOU KNOW THE- SOONER THAN
LATER- JUST TO KEEP TRACK SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN SEE
TRANSPARENCY AND REALLY SEE THE
RESULTS INSTEAD OF. WAITING TO
THE END OF THE STUDY THE PILOT.
IN I CAN THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IN THIS
BILL AND IN FACT ONE. ASPECT OF
THE BILL- THAT- I REALLY WANT
CREDIT CARD FOR CHAIR FOR
PUTTING AND- IS THE BILL.
LITERALLY SAYS IF WE DON'T SEE
A DEMONSTRABLE DROP. IN THE
BEHAVIOR THAT WE ARE LOOKING TO
SEE. AFTER EIGHTEEN MONTHS THE
SYSTEMS COULD BE SHUT DOWN- WE
BASICALLY PUT A NUMBER OF
REQUIREMENTS- TO. ENSURE THAT
WERE EITHER GOING TO SEE QUICK
ACTION AND QUICK RESULTS. FOR
THE SYSTEMS WILL BE SHUT DOWN.
SO I THINK HOPEFULLY THAT WILL
AGAIN CONTINUE TO BUILD-
CONFIDENCE AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY ELSE SO I
WILL GIVE MY COMMENTS I WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU. MISTER
CHIU FOR. WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS- IT'S- AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I FEEL LKE
NOW BECAUSE OF THE RIVER
GROWING REALIZATION ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF REDUCING-
INTERACTIONS AND A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES BETWEEN LAW. LAW
OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC.
BECAUSE OF IMPLICIT BIAS AND
KNOWING THAT CERTAIN PEOPLE GET
STOPPED MORE THAN OTHER PEOPLE.
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS TO
BUILD- AUTOMATION AND- FOR
FAIRNESS AND EQUITY REASONS- I
WANT TO ALSO THANK MR CHIU FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND
WORKING WITH US SO CLOSELY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS WAS THE
ABSOLUTE BEST BILL. THAT WE
COULD BRING FORWARD TO ADDRESS
ALL OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE'VE
HEARD IN THE PAST WHICH ARE ALL
VERY LEGITIMATE- A FEW THINGS
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT ABOUT THE
BILL- BESIDES. THE FACT THAT
IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE CLEARLY
ABOUT REDUCING SPEEDS BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT SPEED. REALLY IS
THE DETERMINING FACTOR BETWEEN
SURVIVING. A COLLISION OR NOT
SURVIVING A COLLISION MORE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE. THAT THIS BILL
DOES REQUIRE. WARNINGS BEFORE
YOU ENTER A SPEED CAMERAS OWN.
NOT OUT OF FAIRNESS BUT
ACTUALLY TO REDUCE THE SPEED
THE PEOPLE ARE DRIVING BECAUSE
WE THINK OF WHAT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO DO HERE IS GET PEOPLE
TO SLOW DOWN. SO WE THINK THAT
HAVING THAT MORNING IN AND OF
ITSELF AND GET PEOPLE TO SLOW
DOWN. AND AS HE MENTIONED IF IT
DOESN'T THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
USE THE SYSTEM ANYMORE. IT ALSO
SAYS THAT IF THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE RESULTS THEY WANT
THEY HAVE TO INVEST IN TRAFFIC
COMING IN ORDER TO USE THE
SYSTEM TO REALLY ENCOURAGE
CITIES. TO LOOK AT THIS
HOLISTICALLY TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS THEY NEED IN THE
ENGINEERING TO MAKE THE ROADS
SAFER. AND THEN SO THAT WE
ADDRESS THE CONCERN ABOUT SPEED
TRAPS. THE MONEY THAT'S
GENERATED CAN'T GO INTO THE
GENERAL FUND OF THE CITY IT
GOES RIGHT BACK INTO THOSE VERY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HAVING THE
TICKETS. TO DO THOSE KINDS OF
ROAD IMPROVEMENTS TO MAKE THOSE
COMMUNITIES SAFER. IN ADDITION
I WOULD SAY THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO SPEED YOU WANT TO GET
A TICKET FROM A SPEED CAMERA
BECAUSE THESE FINES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN WHAT
YOU WOULD GET. FROM A POLICE
OFFICER AND IF YOU'RE LOW
INCOME WE ALSO BUILD IN. A A
REDUCED- FEET FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS SO. THE BILL CENTERS
FAIRNESS IT CENTERS EQUITY AND
IT REALLY HASN'T I TOWARDS THE
GOAL OF REDUCING SPEEDS AND
THAT'S BUILT IN OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN IN THE BILL. I
WANT TO I THINK THEAUTHOR THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER ALSO WANT TO THANK LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR ACT. AND A
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROLMAN
FOR WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH THE
OFFER AT AUTHOR AND MOVING
THEIR OPPOSITION. TAKING THAT
MAKING SURE THIS BILL IS THE
BEST BILL COULD BE AND TAKING
THAT LEAP OF FAITH TO LET THIS
PILOT PLAY OUT TO THE WE CAN
ALSO BE DATA. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE ADDED AS
A JOINT AUTHORS. OF THIS BILL
IF YOU WOULD. BE WILLINGTO
HAVE ME- I WOULD- CERTAINLY
SUPPORTS THIS TODAY AND THE-
MOTION IS. TO SUPPORT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS- DOES ANYBODY HAVE I
FIRST I'D LIKE TO LET THE
AUTHOR- CLOSE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE. ANY CONCERNS YOU HEARD I
WAS GOING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS- BUT. YOU'LL
REALLY APPRECIATE I THINK
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB OF THE
AT. YOU KNOW I TO ADDRESS OUR
CALL FROM AUSTIN. AND SOME OF
HIS. IN SAY THE FOR. WHICH IS.
RED LIGHT CAMERA PROGRAMS
ADMITTEDLY HAD A CHECKERED
HISTORY IN OUR STATE THERE ARE
MANY MANY MANY CHALLENGES WITH
THEM. AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THIS IS DIFFERENT- AN AUTOMATED
SPEED ENFORCEMENT NOT ONLY.
LITERALLY OPERATES DIFFERENTLY.
BUT WE HAVE. LEARNED ALL OF THE
MISTAKES. AND LESSONS FROM THE
PAST TO BUILD AND AS THE CHAIR
SAID FOR EXAMPLE ISSUES OF
EQUITY. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT RATHER THAN- A CRIMINAL
PENALTY OR A POINT ON SOMEONE'S
RECORD THAT IMPACTS THAT
INSURANCE THAT COST HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- MANY FINES IN
THE FIFTY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY CAPT- WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO THINK THROUGH
EQUITY. THIS IS NOT ABOUT
GOTCHA MOMENTS SO THE BILL
REQUIRES. IF YOU'RE DRIVING IN
A ZONE YOU WILL SEE SIGNAGE
THAT SAYS THERE IS A SPEED
SAFETY. SYSTEM HERE- WE ARE
REQUIRING JURISDICTIONS TO
EDUCATE. NEIGHBORHOODS SO THAT
FOLKS KNOW WITH. WITH PLENTY OF
TIME- THAT THERE IS A SPEED
SAFETY SYSTEM- ON TOP OF THAT-
WE- IF THIS IS ULTIMATELY
SUCCESSFUL OUR HOPE IS THE
SYSTEMS ARE MAKING MONEY.
BECAUSE THE IDEA IS PEOPLE STOP
SPEEDING. UP AND THAT'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL GOAL AND TO ENSURE
THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT REVENUE-
WE HAVE BAKED INTO THIS BILL.
AFTER A STRONG SUGGESTION OF
THE CHAIR A REQUIREMENT THAT
ANY REVENUES HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THE COMMUNITIES FOR. STREET
IMPROVEMENTS- AND THEN AFTER A
COUPLE YEARS THOSE REVENUES
WOULD HAVE TO GO TO ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. BUT
AGAIN IF THERE'S NO DOCUMENTED
SUCCESS. THESE PROGRAMS WILL
SHUT DOWN AND THIS IS AGAIN A
PILOT FOR FIVE CITIES THAT
DESPERATELY WANT- LET ME JUST
CLOSE BY THANKING. THE
COALITION REPRESENTING PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES REPRESENTING
LAW ENFORCEMENT. REPRESENTING
TRANSIT PEDESTRIAN BIKE SAFETY
ADVOCATES REPRESENTING SENIORS.
AS I SAID BEFORE THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES BUT IN PARTICULAR. LOS
ANGELES OAKLAND SAN FRACISCO
AND SAN JOSE. AND THEN OF
COURSE I WANT TO JUST AND
BIKING OLOGY- THE TREMENDOUS
ADVOCACY. BORN OUT OF TRAGEDY
OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST LOVED
ONES. DUE TO THIS WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PREVENT IT WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO TRY AND
THAT'S MY ASK OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT WE ALLOW THESE
FIVE CITIES TO PILOT THIS LET'S
SEE IF IT WORKS. WE CAN IMPROVE
IT IF WE NEED TO- BUT I CAN
ASSURE YOU WE'VE SPENT YEARS.
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS PILOT WILL
HOPEFULLY BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS
POSSIBLE. AND WITH THAT ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I BELIEVE I
HEARD WE HAD A MOTION FROM
SOMEONE. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
A SECOND. OUR TO PASS AS
AMENDED ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FREDERICK
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN HI FONG.
STOFAN NOT VERY BERMAN. BERMAN
I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON
KALRA. KALRA KILEY LEE I MEDINA
MEDINA I NAZARIAN. IN THIS AREA
NINE WHEN. WHEN NOT VOTING
O'DONNELL FOR DONALD FIVE WARD.
WARD FIVE WEEKS. WICKS HI.
TWELVE ZERO ZERO THE BILL
WITHOUT LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES NUMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER CHANG IS UP
NEXT WITH AB. TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT- I'M SORRY HERE T CLOSE
THE ROLE IN THAT SO WE'LL HAVE
TO VERY SORRY. OKAY MISTER
CHANG THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- OF
AB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT ALSO IS
A BILL WHICH WORKS TO ENCOURAGE
MORE PEOPLE TO WALK- WEATHER'S
WALKING TO WORK WALKING TO
SCHOOL- THE INCLUDES MORE
PEDESTRIANS UNDER CURRENT LAW
PROJECTIONS COULD BE FINED UP
TO TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR JAY
WALKING EVEN IF THERE ARE NO
CARS ON THE ROAD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE DATA SHOWS THAT
MANY OF THESE JAY WALKING BILLS
ARE. UNIFORMLY NOT FAIRLY
ENFORCING NOT CONSISTENTLY
ENFORCED I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
WHICH WE'LL- TALK ABOUT WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT AB.
AT TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT MISTER
RICHARD MILTON AND MISS ANGIE
SCHMITT. OKAY ARE THEY ON THE
TELEPHONE I BELIEVE THEY ARE ON
THE PHONE SO OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE BRING US OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT. THIS
DOUBLE. DOOR ON THE LINE YOUR
LINES ARE OPEN. WE NEED AYE
I'LL JUMP IN MY NAME IS TINA
SMITH I'M THE AUTHOR OF RIGHT
AWAY REYES CLASS AND A SILENT
EPIDEMIC OF PEDESTRIAN DEATHS
IN AMERICA THAT WAS PUBLISHED
LAST YEAR BY ISLAND PRESS I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT AT TWELVE
THIRTY EIGHT. OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS IN A 50% INCREASE IN
PEDESTRIAN DEATHS IN THE UNITED
STATES ABOUT ONE SIXTH
HAPPENING CALIFORNIA THOSE THAT
ARE KILLED ARE MORE LIKELY TO
BE BLACK HISPANIC ELDERLY
DISABLED LOW INCOME. OR SOME
COMBINATION THEREOF. THE
CULTURAL IN. IN THE CLAIM THE
DEATH INJURY WHEN THEY OCCUR.
ON BEING THE RESULT OF ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO ACTED STUPIDLY
OR MADE A BAD CHOICE. BUT IN
URBAN PLANNING THE RECOGNIZING
THE SYSTEMIC ISSUE AND THE
FAULT LIES WITH THE WIDER
SYSTEM WHICH IS HOSTILE TO
THOSE ON FOOT OR WHEELCHAIR.
WHEN WE MATHIS AGUIAR-CURRY
VERY CLEAR PATTERN ALONG WIDE
MULTI LANE SUBURBAN ARTERIALS
PRIMARILY FOR TRAFFIC EITHER
HIGH END WORK PRODUCT NAY T. AS
FAR AS THE HALF MILE APART.
VETERANS CAN CANNOT. BUILD BUT
I WITH THE NEXT PUNITIVE
REGULATORY AND- FOR NORMAL
RATIONAL DECISIONS ARE
CRIMINALIZED. THE TWENTIETH ARE
MUCH MUCH MORE FOR OPERATION
GROUP THAT ARE TARGETED BY
POLICE. IN EVERY ACCOUNT THAT I
HAVE COME ACROSS IN MY RESEARCH
IN CHICAGO AND NEW YORK AND
SEATTLE BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY YOUNG MEN HAVE BEEN
CITED FOR JAYWALKING. AT WILDLY
DISPROPORTIONATE RATE. IN
ADDITION TO BEING BY WE SAW OUR
LEGALLY CLOSER TO THE NEXT ARE
OFTEN. WITH WHY THE THEY ARE
BEING OR RIGHTLY ANGRY ABOUT
BEING HAPPY FOR SUCH A TRIVIAL
OFFENSE. SOME TOOK AT KIND OF A
YEAH AND THEN THE PRIZE AND-
CAN EASILY ESCALATE INTO A
HUMAN BEING OR A- AN INCIDENT
OF POLICE BRUTALITY. IN IN
ADDITION TO THE TRAUMA
INFLICTED ON THE COMMUNITY THE
SITUATIONS ARE VERY THIN FOR
THE DEPARTMENTS INVOLVED IN
OFTEN THE TAXPAYERS ON THE HOOK.
FOR CONFLICT AND- FURTHER WE
KNOW THAT YOU A- IS NOT. IN
PEDESTRIAN. AT EXPERTS WERE
INTERVIEWED FOR MY BOOK TOLD ME
THEY WERE EVIDENCE THAT YOU ARE
FOR APPROVED SAFETY ON. AND THE
MOST CONSCIENTIOUS HAVE MOVED
AWAY FROM THAT APPROACH COULD
NOT. ONLY PLEASE YOUR HONOR
WHAT MINUTES ARE UP IF YOU CAN
FINISH UP PLEASE. YEAH SORRY
AND FINISHING UP- THE THINKING.
IN THE WORLD I DON'T HAVE AN
EQUIVALENT. INFRACTION AND OP
AT WESTERN TO BE A MOVEMENT TO
DECRIMINALIZE. LAWS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES IS LOCKED UP
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
THINK THAT THE PORT IS. OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE RICHARD
MILTON. YEAH. OFF MISTER MILTON
IF THAT'S YOU WE CAN'T HEAR YOU
OPERATOR CAN YOU HELP US ALL.
OKAY OKAY RIGHT YEAH IS BLINDED-
NO COMING FROM PUNISHMENT MAYBE
MOVE BECAUSE YOUR BIKE. THE
MARKET CALL. THANKS I'M SORRY
WE CAN'T HEAR THE WITH. AB ONE
MORE TRY. HOLD UP WELL- YEAH
I'M WRITER COULD YOU SEND
WITNESS SORRY MR I'M SORRY MR
MILLER WHO CAN'T HEAR YOU. I'M
A SORRY ABOUT THE TECHNICAL- WE
NO OFF ON FILE SO WITH THAT IF
WE PLEASE UP PHONE LINES TO
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
AND IF MR MILTON CALLS BACK IF
WE CAN HEAR HIM WE WILL GIVE US
TWO MINUTES OF THAT TIME. I IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE CHAMBERS
FIRST. ANYONE IN THE WOMEN'S
ROOM NO OKAY OPERATOR YOU CAN
OPEN UP THE- LINE FOR AB.
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT. AND LATER
GERMAN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO-
JOINT SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR
A. B. TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THIS TIME WE ABOUT
NINE IN OUR QUEUE. AND WE'LL
START WITH NUMBER THREE FORTY
YOUR HEAD. YES MADAM CHAIR MIKE
CARROLL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW POVERTY- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ENERGY MY BOOK
TONIGHT THANK YOU. WHEN I MOVED
TO LINE THREE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN
MAGICIAN I LIVE IN HILLSBOROUGH
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NEXT TO BE NUMBER THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE SEVENTEEN LINES OPEN.
WILL MOVE TO NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
FIVE- PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI BRIAN
**** ONE O'CLOCK SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. TWO OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS YURI DONNA SOMEONE
NUMBER OF NATIONAL MOTORS
ASSOCIATION AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL ON THE GROUNDS THAT WOULD
CREATE CHAOS ON THE ROLE OF THE
SHIP THE RESPONSIBILITIES THANK
YOU THAT SAID WE DON'T TAKE
TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER. EXCUSE NUMBER
TWO FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHE. TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO NUMBER
THREE TEN THREE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS LAUREN
WELL SOME OF THE FOR THE MARIN
COUNTY BICYCLE COALITION GOING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. NOW GO TO NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
YES YES YOUR LINES OPEN WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY NOT SAME NUMBER
CANNOT BEVERLY AGAIN ENOUGH
SUPPORT THIS BILL. FROM THE-
CATHOLIC. NEXT TO ME NUMBER TWO
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHERO WILL BE IN SAN FRANCISCO-
MY HUSBAND AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL STRONGLY THANK YOU. SIX OF
THE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY KIDDING
LAWRENCE OF CONSIDER GROW- IN
SUPPORT- IT'S STILL IMPORTANT
TO STOP SPEEDING ISSUES AND
SAFETY FOR WALKERS IS A BIG
PROBLEM FOR US IN OUR COMMUNITY
TO THANK YOU. NEXUS NUMBER
THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SAN FRANCISCO- WHAT THE
BILL. AND AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE MANAGER THANK
YOU OPERATOR WE'LL TAKE IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SEE
IF ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS DAVIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I GUESS I GUESS MY
QUESTION HERE IS ONE OF THE
THINGS I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
IS- WE JUST LOST SOMEONE. J.
WATKINS BEEN AFFECTED FORTY
YEAR OLD GENTLEMAN AND THEY GET
HIT BY A CAR BUT TO BLOCK MY
HOUSE WE'VE ALSO IN THE LAST
YEAR. LOSS ANOTHER CHILD THAT
J. WALKED IN. I GUESS MY
CONCERN IS AN ADULT WE CAN MAKE
PRETTY GOOD JUDGMENTS. BUT IS
THERE AN AGE ON THIS BECAUSE AN
EIGHT YEAR OLD OR A- YEAR OLDS.
FIRST CHILDREN THAT ARE
WATCHING OTHER PEOPLE DOING
THIS BY EXAMPLE THINKING WELL
IF THEY CAN DO WHAT I CAN DO IT
I JUST. THAT'S MY CONCERN IS
YOU KNOW. IN THE DOOR THE
POLICE ARE GONNA KNOW HOW OLD
ARE YOU I UNDERSTAND THE FINE
PART. I'M JUST REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT. BEING ABLE TO JUST YOU
KNOW IF IT'S RED LIGHT BUT I
THINK I CAN WALK AND I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY I CAN GO AHEAD AND
CROSS OVER. THAT'S MY CONCERN
WHEN IT COMES TO SAFETY IN LIFE
IT ESPECIALLY WE JUST. GO AHEAD
AND PASS THE BILL WITH THE
PILOT PROGRAM BECAUSE OF
SPEEDING AND THAT'S A CONCERN
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW SO. IF YOU
COULD JUST- MAYBE CAN YOU GIVE
ME YOUR SIDE TO THAT IT'S
REALLY THE H. A LOT THAT'S
REALLY HITTING ME THANK YOU.
NOT FOR YOUR QUESTION. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE SET AN AGE LIMIT. IN
THIS BUT- AS AS A PARENT IF
YOUR CHILD IS A CERTAIN AGE I
WOULD HOPE THEY WOULD BE
WALKING WITH THEIR PARENTS. I
THINK THERE ARE DAYS WHERE THEY
CAN'T MAKE THOSE JUDGMENTS BUT
I I'M HAPPY TO TALK TO MY STAFF
AND SEE. IF THERE IS AN AGE
LIMIT ON THE BILL. WHY SEE ANY.
ELSE WHICH IS- I WANT TO THANK
YOU BRING THIS. I THINK THE- IS
A VERY GOOD BILL. AND JUST TO
ANSWER. MYSTIQUE IS VERY
REASONABLE CONCERN I THINK THAT
THAT IS A BIG CONCERN. MY
CHILD. IS GOING TO NOT. J. WALK
WHEN IT'S DANGEROUS. NOT
BECAUSE OF THE THREAT OF
FORGETTING A TICKET BECAUSE IS
VERY RARELY A POLICE OFFICER
AROUND. SHE'S GOING TO LEARN
NOT TO J. WALK WHEN IT'S
DANGEROUS BECAUSE I WILL
EXPLAIN TO HER THE DANGER. OF
WALKING IN TRAFFIC- THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE PEOPLE
SAFER I DON'T THINK ANY THERE
ARE MANY TIMES WHERE PEOPLE.
STOP AND LOOK AROUND AND CHOOSE
TO DO SOMETHING DANGEROUS JUST
BECAUSE THERE'S NO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IS A LOT OF THINGS
THAT PEOPLE CAN DO THAT ARE
DANGERS THAT WE DON'T
CRIMINALIZE- I DON'T. WANT TO
TELL MY DAUGHTER NOT TO JUMP
OUT OF A SECOND FLOOR WINDOW
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT GET ARRESTED.
I TRY TO EXPLAIN THE DANGERS
FOR HER AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO TREAT. J. WALKING IN
THE SAME WAY AND ADDITIONALLY.
IN MANY PLACES WE HAVE REALLY
MADE WALKING VERY INCONVENIENT
AND UNPLEASANT. BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO WALK REALLY FAR
SOMETIMES TO GET TO WITH THE
LEGAL CROSSWALK. AND HOPEFULLY
THIS WILL ALSO ENCOURAGE CITIES
TO LOOK AT THE WEIGHTED
ENGINEER THEIR STREETS TO MAKE
THE MORE PLEASANT. AND LASTLY
I'LL JUST SAY THAT AS SOMEONE
WHO WALKS AROUND. SACRAMENTO A
LOT MYSELF AT NIGHT. THERE ARE
TIMES WHERE I DON'T FEEL SAFE
TO NINETY ONE. SO I THINK THAT
THERE ARE REASONS WHY WE SHOULD
GIVE PEOPLE. THE ABILITY TO USE
THEIR OWN COMMONSENSE- WHEN
THEY CROSS THE STREET. RATHER
THE AND MAKE OUR STREETS SAFER
IN TERMS OF THE WAY TO DESIGN.
AND NOT THINK THAT SOMEBODY
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE GOING TO
GET A TICKET IS GOING TO BE THE
PRIME MOTIVATOR AS TO WHETHER
THEY ACT. SAFELY OR DANGEROUSLY
SO I THINK THIS IS A VERY GOOD
BILL I THINK THAT. REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF TICKETS THAT PEOPLE
ARE GIVEN FINES AND SOMETIMES
VERY UNFAIRLY USING A LOT OF
IMPLICIT BIAS IN A LOT OF
BULLYING BEHAVIOR. IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO STOP AND I
THINK THAT THIS BILL IS A GOOD
STEP TO DO THAT. SO I DID WE
HAVE A MOTION I FEEL LIKE I
HEARD ABOUT EIGHT DIFFERENT
MOTIONS ABOUT EIGHT DIFFERENT
SETTINGS SO. YOU CAN PICK
WHOEVER YOU SAW FIRST. AS A
MOTION AND A SECOND. AND THE-
MOTION IS TO DO A TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE JUST-
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU CAN WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO FOR
CREATIONS FRIEDMAN. HI.
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG I BERMAN.
BERMAN HI CAN. CUNNINGHAM ON
DALY DAILY I DAVIES. DAVIES NOW
DAVIS NOW GIPSON GIPSON HI
KALRA. KALRA KILEY THE I'M
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN. THIS
AREA I WENT PHËN N<c.cyan></c>
O'DONNELL. HOLD ON. HI DONALD
HI WARD WARD I WICKS. OKAY. TWO
TWELVE TO GO TO THE BILL'S OUT
LIBERAL OPEN THANK YOU NEXT WE
HAVE EDU THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE
MISTER WOULD WITH AB FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND GOD BLESS YOU ALL THANK
YOU. THIS COMMITTEE IS WELL
AWARE OF THE MYRIAD WAYS IN
WHICH THE DIGITAL DIVIDE HAS
MANIFESTED ITSELF THROUGHOUT
THERE ARE STATE THIS PAST YEAR.
THE SOLUTION I PUT FORWARD PUT
PUT FORTH IN AB FORTY ONE ARE
NOT SILVER BULLETS THEY ARE
IMPORTANT STEPS AS WE WORK
TOGETHER TO BRING CALIFORNIA'S
DATE INFRASTRUCTURE TO TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. SINCE TAKING
OFFICE COMMONSENSE EXPANSION OF
RURAL BROADBAND ACCESS HAS BEEN
A PRIORITY OF MINE. THE CONCEPT
OF DIG ONCE IS NOT A NEW POLICY
AREA FOR ME. WELL I AM
FRUSTRATED THE LACK OF PROGRESS
SINCE I FIRST RAISED THE ISSUE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN I'M
HEARTENED BY A COMMITMENT FROM
CALTRANS TO MAKE THIS RIGHT. MY
OFFICE IS TO WAY FOR SPECIFICS
WHAT WE BELIEVE THERE IS- THERE
HAS ONLY BEEN A SINGLE INSTANCE
OF DIG ONCE UTILIZED SINCE I
STARTEDWORKING ON THAT. THIS
IS NOT ENOUGH. YOU CAN'T TELL
ME THAT IN ALL OF OUR ROADWAY
IMPROVEMENT- BRUCKMAN'S PASSING
THROUGH ALL OF OUR UNDERSERVED
CONSTITUENCIES THAT THERE'S
ONLY BEEN ONE OPPORTUNITY IN
THE LAST FOUR YEARS. TO DIG
ONCE. WE CANNOT FACILITATE
SIMPLE EFFICIENCIES IT
DRASTICALLY SAVE ON BUILDING
COSTS WHEN THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
WILL CONTINUE TO WROTE. QUOTE
EQUITY THE DIGITAL TO THE
DIGITAL I WILL CONTINUE TO
ROADS. EQUITY IN OUR STATE PUT
SIMPLY AS WE UPGRADE OUR STATE
ROADWAYS WE NEED TO DETERMINE
HOW. NOT IF BROADBAND IS A PART
OF THAT IMMINENT-
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT I
CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER TIME
DELAY CON DO IT THEN WHEN WE
HAVE THE GROUND OPEN UP
ALREADY. WE'RE GOING TO
INVESTING CRITICAL IMPROVEMENTS
TO OUR INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED
TO ASK A LITTLE MORE OF OUR
PARTNERS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
PRINT PART FRANKLY I THINK
WE'VE INCREASED TREND WITH WE
NEED INCREASED TRANSFER PARENTS
SEE NOW BROADBAND IS ROLLED OUT
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WILL BE
SURE THAT EVERY HOUSEHOLD IS
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED AS A
POTENTIAL CUSTOMER WHEN WE
BUILD OUT INFRASTRUCTURE.
NEEDED TO BETTER THEIR
INSTANCES IN MY DISTRICT WHERE
BUSINESSES OR INDIVIDUALS TO
PAY TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. TO BRING BROADBAND
SERVICE TO THEIR PARCEL.
OPPOSITION FROM OF. SIX THAT
COMMUNITIES SHOULD JUST USE THE
LINE EXTENSION PROGRAM. I KNOW
THIS IS A TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. BUT THIS LINE
EXTENSION PROGRAM- ISN'T
WORKING QUITE IS IT WORKING
WELL. I FEAR THIS SENT TO ME IS
BEING PASSED THROUGH NOT
BECAUSE THEY ARE PROFITABLE
BECAUSE THEY AREN'T PROFITABLE
ENOUGH RIGHT NOW WE'RE LETTING
CURRENT INCOME IT'S CARVE UP
OUR RURAL INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
THE SAME FRENZY. AS A SOTHEBY'S
ART AUCTION HIS BITTERS NGUYEN
AND YOU HAVE TO BE FABULOUSLY
WEALTHY TO GET IN THE DOOR. WE
EVEN HOPE THAT NARROW
EXTENSIONS WOULD HAVE CONNECTED
OTHERS ALONG THE WAY FOR MORE
INDIVIDUALS NEAR THE
DESTINATION BUT THAT'S SIMPLY
NOT THE CASE. BRITAIN DESIRE OF
THE INDIVIDUAL AHEAD OF THE
GOOD OF THE COMMUNITY. ONE
ENTITY PAIN STAGGERING SUMS IS
NOT WHAT WE WHAT THE MARKET
DICTATES IT'S BROADBAND
GERRYMANDERING. ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS CHOICE
STERLING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S RECORD OF
WORK OFFICE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
A SOLUTION THAT SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERS EACH A POTENTIAL
CUSTOMER FOR THIS VITAL
RESOURCE EVERY TIME A SHOVEL
BREAKS GROUND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IBM. THANK YOU
OPERATOR CAN WE PLEASE HAVE
CHOI STERLING. SB THIRTY FORTY
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR
WHAT IT MEANS TO DELIVER
BROADBAND TO OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES. THE HIGHWAYS THAT
BISECTED STATE MIGHT SEE MAJOR
IMPROVEMENTS ONLY ONCE IN MY
LIFETIME. WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
MISS ANY OPPORTUNITY TO INSTALL
HIGH SPEED FIBER OPTIC CABLE.
AS YOU NO BIG ONE DRASTICALLY
SAVE ON COSTS. IDENTIFYING
STANDARDS FOR OUR STATE
ROADWAYS IS MERELY A
PRACTICALITY. LET ME ASSURE YOU
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY FOR THE
PUBLIC GOOD. CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS A PUBLIC
POLICY PRIORITY FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT HEALTHCARE
EDUCATION AGRICULTURE AND
TRANSPORTATION. NAMELY
OPERATIONS MAINTENANCE ROAD
SAFETY TRAFFIC FLOW THE ADVENT
OF THE THOMAS CARS AND TRUCKS.
DR WOODS BILL IS A KEY PART OF
THE PRACTICAL PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION STAGE OF
BRIDGING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
MOVING FORWARD TO ACTUALLY
BUILDING OUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER BILLS
MOVING THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
WHICH WILL HELP THE STATE WORK
WITH NEW FEDERAL INVESTMENT AND
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY FOR FUNDING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TRIBES AND
NONPROFIT. PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR ARE KEY TO
COST EFFECTIVELY MEETING OUR
IMMEDIATE AND FUTURE BROADBAND
NEEDS. BIG ONE IS THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT. I HOPE YOU WILL
ALSO HEAR DOCTOR WOULD APPEAL.
FOR INCREASED TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURE DISCLOSURES IN
INTERNET SERVICE AREAS. ONLY
WHEN WE UNDERSTAND THE GAPS CAN
WE PROPERLY SERVE OUR
CONSTITUENCY. AB FORTY ONE IS A
NECESSARY STEP IN GIVING OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES THE MEANS. TO
ACTUALLY FINALLY GET ON THE-
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH I.
TWO IT IS IN UP. THE FIRST IS
HERE IN THE ROOM OR CLOSE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FOR OROZCO WITH CAL CABLE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION-
FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING DILIGENTLY ON
THIS BILL WE HAD SOME GREAT
MEETINGS TO DISCUSS OUR
OPPOSITION. AND I THINK
RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN SOME
AMENDMENTS TO IMPROVE THE
PORTION DEALING WITH THE-
CONDUIT INSTALLATION- IT'S NOW
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL WHICH IS ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST ISSUE SO THAT
WAS ADDRESSED IN THE LATEST
MOMENT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT. AND THEN ALSO IN
IDENTIFYING THE APPROPRIATE
LOCATIONS WHERE CON DO IT
SHOULD BE INSTALLED- PREVIOUSLY
AND HAVE BEEN SOME LANGUAGE
ADDRESSING- THE A PREVIOUS
REPORT FROM THE PC THERE WAS
OUTDATED. BUT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IS NOW THE BROADBAND
COUNCIL I STILL THINK THAT MANY
SOME WORK THERE I'VE DISCUSSES
WITH THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
I THINK PROBABLY TO MAKE THAT
THE EASIEST APPROACH IT SHOULD
BE JUST AREAS IDENTIFIED. THAT
HAVE LESS THAN- PROBLEMS
BECAUSE OF TWENTY FIVE AND
THREE I THINK THAT OULD MAKE
IT THE MOST SIMPLISTIC AND WE
COULD WORK WITH THE CALTRANS
AND IDENTIFYING THOSE AREAS. SO
THIS SEASON MY MAJOR
IMPROVEMENTS IN IT HOWEVER WE
ARE STILL OPPOSED BECAUSE OF
THE TRANSPARENCY OF RELEASING
CONFIDENTIAL PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS COMMITTEE WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT
ISSUE. BUT THANK THE. COMMITTEE
FOR THE IMPROVEMENTS THE BILL.
HILL US POST THE MEASURE THAT
OVERALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THEN WE HAVE STEVE CARLSON
ON THE PHONE. OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE BY MISTER CARLSON.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON- CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS OUNSEL FOR CPA WHERE
THE TRADE ASSOCIATION. FOR THE
WIRELESS COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY AND UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE OPPOSED TO AB FORTY ONE.
CTIA THAT'S MEMBERS FULLY
SUPPORT IT COLLABORATED WITH
POLYMET POLICY MAKERS AND
REGULATORS TO ENHANCE BROADBAND
ACCESS FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD AND AGREE-
COMPLETELY ON THE NEED FOR
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT. AS SUCH
OUR OBJECTIONS ARE NOT TO THE
PURPOSE AND INTENT OF THE DIG
ONE SECTION TO THE BILL. AND WE
SUPPORT EXPLORING COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS TO USE CONDUIT
INSTALLED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
BUT INDICATED BY MISTER ROSCOE-
THE AMENDMENT- HAVE BEEN ARE-
BENEFICIAL AND ARE CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS TO FURTHER
CLARIFY ASPECTS OF THAT SECTION.
REGRETTABLY WE MUST OPPOSE
SECTION ONE IN ITS ENTIRETY
THAT REQUIRES COMPETITIVE
COMPANIES TO BROADCAST THE BILL
THAT PLANS. PUBLISHING COMPANY
TO PUBLICIZE THE COMPANY
DEPLOYMENT PLANS TO EVERY
HOUSEHOLD DOES NOT ADVANCE THE
BILL OR DO YOU WANT. INSTEAD IT
FORCES COMPANIES TO REPORT AND
COMMUNICATE BUSINESS PLAN- TO
PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING
PRICING INFORMATION ALSO TO
COMPETITORS WHICH COULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT COMPETITIVE AND I
TRUST IMPLICATIONS. ALSO PUBLIC
FUNDING ON THE PATIENT
PUBLICIZING THE LOCATION OF
FACILITIES JEOPARDIZES THE
SECURITY OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
TO CONNECT NETWORK VULNERABLE
TO ACT OF VANDALISM THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPACTS. WE AGREED TO PROVE
BABSON IMPROVED BABSON NEEDED
ON THE FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION WITHIN THE PROCESS
OF FINALIZING THOSE RULES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY UNTIL THAT ISSUE
IS THE IS THE DRESSED WE MUST
RESPECTIVELY OPPOSE. AB FORTY
ONE IN ASKING ABOUT. THANK YOU
MUCH. THE OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE FIRST OF ALL THERE TO
ANYONE ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK TO ANYONE IN
THE WITNESS ROOM. K. OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF AB
FORTY ONE. AND LATER GERMAN
INSURANCE SUPPORT PROPOSITION
TO AB FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND AT THIS TIME-
WE DO OF ABOUT TWO IN OUR QUEUE.
WE'LL START WITH NUMBER THREE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT AFTER ON BEHALF OF OKAY
IN SUPPORT. NEXT TO ME NUMBER
THREE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAKES ALL OF ON THE UP
OF FRONTIER COMMUNICATIONS A
PUBLIC UNLESS AMENDED WITH
CONCERNS AROUND SECTION ONE OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
MANSION. OKAY WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
AMONG'S COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
HAVE ONE QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR- CERTAINLY THERE'S A LOT
OF MERIT TO THE DIG ONCE POLICY
AND I AM SUPPORT OF THAT MAYBE
YOU COULD ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION IN TERMS OF THE
PROPRIETARY NATURE OF. OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE SECURITY
SIDE OF IT- ON SECTION ONE.
WELL I CAN YOU. CAN YOU CAN YOU
CAN YOU CAN JUST YOUR CLOTHES
IF YOU LIKE I DON'T HAVE TO NOT
HAPPEN I'M ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION- YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE KNOW
WHERE. WHERE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IS- AND IT DOESN'T NEED TO MEAN
MEAN TO. THAT WE NEED TO THE
WORLD TO KNOW WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS BUT BUT
INTERESTED PARTIES SHOULD BE
ABLE TO KNOW WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SO. HAD THAT
HAPPEN MAYBE- MAYBE CALTRANS
WOULDN'T HAVE- DESTROYED A
FIBER OPTIC LINE IN MY DISTRICT
AND THAT THE WHOLE NORTH COAST
OUT OF INTERNET ACCESS IF
YOU'VE GOT A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO- YOU KNOW SO. I GUESS IF
YOU WOULD EVER CONCERNED ABOUT
SECURITY ISSUES OF PEOPLE KNOW
WHERE OUR WATER SUPPLIES ARE
THEY KNOW WE'RE ELECTRIC
SUPPLIES ARE- THESE ARE BURIED
FOR THE MOST PART AND- AND
THOSE THAT AREN'T. RUNNING ON
LINES AND SO I UNDERSTAND THE
THAT THERE ARE SECURITY
CONCERNS BUT THEY'RE SIX
SECURITY CONCERNS ABOUT ALL OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE. I THINK
THERE ARE WAYS TO WORK AROUND
THAT AND WE CONTINUE. TO LOOK
FOR WAYS TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. OKAY THE SURVEY
DANCER- SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- I DO MOTION
SECOND. REALLY WE GET OCEAN FOR
MR BERMAN SECOND FROM THE
CHILLY AT THE- WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IBM. A SECONDARY CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN.
FONG AND A FONDO BERMAN BERMAN
I CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON KALRA.
THREE LI HI MEDINA. MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. WHEN. WHEN NO
O'DONNELL. DONALD I WARD. WARD
I WICKS. SEVEN TWO SEVEN ZERO
LOOK AT THE ROLE OF AN- OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR SUBJECT- I BELIEVE MR
BERMAN ARE YOU READY FOR FIVE
SIXTEEN AB SEVEN NINE SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER JOHN
COLLEAGUES AB SEVEN NINE SIX
SIX TO IMPROVE AND REFINE THE
CALIFORNIA NEW MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM TO ENSURE ITS CONTINUED
SUCCESS AND EFFECTIVENESS. AB
SEVENTY SIX WONDERFUL HIGH
LESSONS LEARNED AND ADOPT
FEDERAL MOTOR VOTER TIMELINE
FOR TIMELY TRANSMITTAL OF VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION FROM
THE DMV TO THE SECTOR STATE.
WOULD ALSO QUALIFY NUMBER OF
BEST PRACTICES FROM THE ONGOING
LEGAL SETTLEMENT INCLUDING DATA
REPORTING ON PROCESSING TIMES
TRAINING OF DMV AND SECRETARY
OF STATE STAFF. AND MAINTAINING
COORDINATORS AT THE DMV AND SOS
TO MONITOR COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FEDERAL AND STATE MOTOR VOTER
LAWS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON AB SEVENTY SIX. I
THINK VERY MUCH. THE AWARENESS
IS IN SUPPORT OF YOUR BILL. TWO
HI- I BELIEVE- THE OPERATOR
WILL YOU- OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OPERATOR THE WITNESS FUNDS ARE
OPEN WELL. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHIU FRIEDMAN AND IF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JONATHAN MARKER AND I'M
A PROGRAM MANAGER AT CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE JUSTIFYING AS A CO
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY SIX CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE IS A NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
BUILDING AN INCLUSIVE DEMOCRACY
AND CLOSING VOTER PARTICIPATION
GAP IN CALIFORNIA. TODAY WE ARE
CONTINUING THE FIGHT TO CREATE
A REPRESENTATIVE ELECTORATE
ALONGSIDE THE OTHER CO SPONSORS
OF EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX.
ILLEGAL AND VOTERS THE
CALIFORNIA AN ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION. AB SEVEN NINE SIX WITH
THE LITTLE FIVE BEST PRACTICES
RELATING TO CALIFORNIA'S MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM WHICH LAUNCHED AT
THE DMB THREE YEARS AGO. THE
PROGRAM HAS STREAMLINED THE
VOTER REGISTRATION PROCESS I
HAVE MADE IT MORE CONVENIENT
THAN EVER FOR CUSTOMERS TO
REGISTER TO VOTE OR UPDATE
THEIR REGISTRATION. SINCE THE
ROLLOUT OF THE PROGRAM OVER
TWELVE MILLION VOTER
REGISTRATION TRANSACTIONS HAVE
TAKEN PLACE AT THE DMV
INCLUDING OVER NINE MILLION WE
REGISTRATIONS AND OVER THREE
MILLION NEW VOTERS BEING ADDED
TO THE GOAL. OF THE RESULT
CALIFORNIA ANNOUNCES HIRING
HIGHEST MOTOR REGISTRATION RATE
IN RECENT HISTORY ACCORDING TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE 88% OF
CALIFORNIANS ELIGIBLE
POPULATION IS CURRENTLY
REGISTERED TO VOTE. DESPITE THE
MAJOR ADVANCES WE'VE MADE MORE
THAN THREE MILLION ELIGIBLE
DOLPHIN CALIFORNIA STILL REMAIN
ON REGISTERED A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF WHOM
ARE UNDER. GROUPS IN ADDITION
TO LEADING TO CLOSE THIS GAP
THE ACCURACY OF OUR VOTER ROLLS
BECOMES INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT
AS MORE CALIFORNIANS. EXPECT TO
RECEIVE THE CALIFORNIA.
CONTINUE TO OVERSEE AND IMPROVE
TO CALIFORNIA MOTOR VOTER.
PROGRAM ARE STILL THE AT.
EIGHTY FIVE NINETY SIX TO ALLOW
FOR THE IMPROVE. BY CODIFYING
BEST PRACTICES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN PLACE DUE TO A
TOTAL AGREEMENT WITH THE DMB
THAT EFFECTIVE BUYER IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. AN AYE
VOTE FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS BRINGING DOWN HYPER
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE
BONTA EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX.
ACLU ON OUR PARTNER SPENT MANY
YEARS ADVOCATING TO INCREASE
THE FAIRNESS AND EFFICIENCY OF
THE CALIFORNIA MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM IN RECENT YEARS THE
ADVOCATE TAKING THE FORM OF A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT THE DMB
AND SECRETARY OF STATE. OTHER
REQUIRED BY THAT SETTLEMENT
BEING THE SECRETARY HAD THEM
AND PROVIDING DETAILED MONTHLY
REPORTS ABOUT THE PROCESSING
AND VOTER AND A VOTER
REGISTRATION APPLICATIONS AT
THE DMV AS WELL AS REGULARLY
MEETING WITH THAT DISCUSS. THE
CONTENTS OF THIS REPORT. THE
TRANSPARENCY IN ACCOUNTING THE
PETER. CREATED THE DMB. HAVE A
LOT. TO IDENTIFY AND- RESOLVE.
ISSUES THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
A REGISTRATION. IT ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED
CALIFORNIA COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL ELECTION LAW.
PERSONALLY HOWEVER THE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH HAVE BEEN SO
CRITICAL TO TRANSFORMING THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM INTO THE
SUCCESS IT IS TODAY BULLETS
FIRED EARLY TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX WILL
CODIFY BEST PRACTICES ALREADY
IN PLACE AT THE N. B. AS A
RESULT OF THE SETTLEMENT I WILL
CREATE MORE CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE NBA
WORKSTREAM. EITHER COMMONSENSE
PROVISIONS LIKE REQUIRING THE
DMB TO CONTINUE TRACKING AND
REPORTING REGISTRATION
PROCESSING TIME AND REQUIRING
THE SECRETARY INDIAN BE TO
TRAIN RELEVANT STAFF AND HOW
THE MOTHER. BIRD MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM MARKS. BY CLEARLY
DEFINING TIMELINE FOR DAM TO
PROPER THESE RECORD. THIS BILL
ALL I'M SURE THE L. AND-
WISHING TO REGISTER DANTE ARE
NOT DISENFRANCHISED BECAUSE OF
BACKLOGS AND THE NBA'S MAIL
BROWN. ADMINISTRATIVE RED TAPE.
DESPITE THE SIGNIFICANT
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM MORE MUST BE DONE TO
PERMANENTLY SECURE RECENT
IMPROVEMENTS AND TO BRING THE
THREE MILLION ELIGIBLEBUT
UNREGISTERED CALIFORNIANS INTO
OUR DEMOCRACY. EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX THE PRACTICAL GOOD
GOVERNMENT MEASURE AND FORTY
THREE CENTS- STUCK THE OSCAR
EITHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I DON'T BELIEVE WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. GREAT- SO WE WILL
NOW I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBERS I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY ROOMS- OPERATOR WHEN
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTY SIX. AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN NINE SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND ONE ZERO
FOR SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE THREE IN THE QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT HIS NAME- ORGANIZATION
AND SUPPORT OR SUPPORT. GO
AHEAD AND WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING DOOR ROSE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
CO SPONSORS OF AB SEVEN NINE
SIX IN STRONG SUPPORT I'VE ALSO
BEEN ASKED BY MELISSA ROMERO
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
BE NUMBER THREE SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DEVON ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
EXHIBIT NUMBER NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES WITH THE
FULFILL CARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY. ROBERT W. ASK IF
THERE'S ANY- MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
THAT WOULD WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. AB. NINE SEVEN SIX.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CAN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHTS WILL NOT BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. SEEING NONE. WELL I
LIKE YOU TO CLOSE YOUR MOTION
SECOND I APPRECIATE THE
WONDERFUL SUPPORT AND THE LACK
OF OPPOSITION- RESPECT US ROAD.
A SECOND I PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. FONG
NO FONG NO BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NO DAILY
DAILY I DAVIES FROM DAVIES NO
GIPSON. KALRA LEE LI HI MEDINA.
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN. WHEN
DONALD SO DONALD I WARD. WARD I
WICKS. SIX THREE. SIX THREE
WILL KEEP SEVEN OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THE WOMAN. THE MOVE
YOUR LAST BUILT ON THE FILE AB
THREE SIX THREE MEDINA. BEGAN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND SPONSORS FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB THREE
SIXTY THREE WHICH SEEKS TO
MODERNIZE AND STREAMLINE THE
VOTE VOUCHER INCENTIVE PROGRAM
A SUBPROGRAM WITHIN THE LARGER
MOYER PROGRAM. AB TO RESIST
SIXTY THREE WILL MAKE THE
FOLLOWING CHANGES TO THE MOYER
THE I. P. PROGRAM ELIMINATES
OUTDATED MODEL YEAR
RESTRICTIONS PROVIDED THAT THE
VEHICLE CAN BE REGISTERED IN
THE STATE BY THE DMZ. IT
INCLUDES EXPANDED VEHICLE TYPE
ELIGIBILITY ALLOWS FOR ENGINE
REPLACEMENTS ALLOWS LEASE
FLEETS TO PARTICIPATE WITH
RESTRICTIONS. EXPANDS
ELIGIBILITY TO ALLOW TRUCKS
PRIMARILY OPERATING IN THE
STATE THE PREVIOUSLY REGISTERED
OUT OF STATE. EXPANDS
ELIGIBILITY OF THE VIP PROGRAM
MORE STREAMLINED APPROACH TO
LARGE FLEET. WHILE KEEPING
CERTAIN SIZE LIMITATIONS IN
PLACE. AB THREE SIXTY THREE
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE CAR TO
PREPARE AN ISSUE REVISED
GUIDELINES BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE SIXTY
THREE ON THE PHONE R. MICHAEL
RICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLE
COALITION AND ROBERTO RODRIGUEZ
OWNER AND OPERATOR. OF MC
TRACKING. OKAY I'LL WILL WAS
WOULD BE COOL. PRICE FIRST AND
THEY WERE GOING TO REVERT TO A
OF A MAGICAL THIS IS A SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES OF THAT. PLEASE
BEGIN. YES THANK YOU AND GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
NICOLE RICE PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLE
COALITION. AND WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF AB THREE SIX THREE.
I WANT TO START BY THINKING AYE
CHAIRMAN FREEMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
COLLABORATION AND DISCUSSION ON
THIS BILL. AND THEN TO THE
AUTHOR OR CHAMPION THIS
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE. SIMPLY
PUT AB THREE SIX THREE IS ABOUT
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S AIR
QUALITY TODAY. BY CHEATING NEAR
TERM EMISSION REDUCTION A GOAL
THAT IS THE MISSION OF OUR
COALITION. JUST LAST WEEK THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
RELEASED THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STATE A PAIR REPORT AND AS AN
EXAMPLE FRESNO COUNTY AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY RECEIVED FAILING
GRADES. ADDED MANY OTHER
COUNTIES IN THE STATE. NOT ONLY
IS THIS UNACCEPTABLE BUT IT'S
UNNECESSARY AND AB THREE SIX
THREE OFFERS A MUCH NEEDED
SOLUTION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA STATED HEAVY DUTY DIESEL
TRUCKS ARE A MAJOR SOURCE OF
HARMFUL AIR POLLUTANTS. AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES NEAR
FREIGHT CORRIDORS. THIS BILL
REVISES THE CAL MALAYER PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVES FOR ELIGIBLE MOBILE
SOURCE PROD PROJECTS. DEPLOYED
IN THESE COMMUNITIES AND IT
STREAMLINED AND MODERNIZED THE
VIP PROGRAM TO FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE THE IMMEDIATE
DEPLOYMENT OF CLEAN. HEAVY DUTY
LOW KNOCKS TRACK. C. V. THEME
COME THE I TRY. TO ZERO
EMISSION FUTURE BUT IN THE
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE SPACE TODAY
THEIR OWN MISSION VEHICLES ARE
NOT COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE AND
WON'T BE ABLE TO DISPLACE THE
LEGACY DIESEL TRUCK. ON A ONE
FOR ONE BASIS FOR AT LEAST
ANOTHER SEVEN TO TEN YEARS. AB
THREE SIX THREE COMPLIMENTS THE
STATE'S LONG TERM GOAL BY
PLACING CLEAN TRUCKS ON THE
ROAD TODAY SO IF YOU SUPPORT
IMPROVE THE AIR QUALITY TODAY.
AND BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES
TODAY THAT WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB THREE SIX THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA ROBERTO AND THE
NEED TO SELL THE WITNESS THAT
THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES. PLEASE REPEAT. YEAH I'M
A MEMBER OF THE- YEAH I WAS
WASHED THAT MORNING. RIGHT WHEN
I GET BACK HEALTH WHAT WE- AND
I BEING- I MEAN FIFTY YEARS OF
THE TRUCK DRIVER ALL
INDEPENDENT. AND I FORGOT WHILE
OUR DATE. AND YEAH RIGHT NOW
WITH THE- RIGHT AND- I I'M
GOING. AB MANY INDEPENDENT
RECORD ON OR GREATER ALL. WE
NEED TO HELP YOU- BY. YOU ARE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OPTION- WHAT.
PROGRAMS THAT WORK WELL. BOB
MAHER PROGRAM DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH. ONE AND IT TAKES A LOT-
I KNOW THAT. OUR GOAL. AND I
THINK THAT THEY WERE HAVING A
HARD TIME HEARING YOUR BURROW-
STILL. WE WANT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOUR SUPPORT. YEAH OKAY WE
REGISTERED YOUR SUPPORT I
APOLOGIZE I THINK WE'RE HAVING
A HARD TIME HEARING YOU LOSE-
BUT WE WANT TO. SO OKAY IF YOU
DON'T MIND A LITTLE MOVED TO
THE TO THE OPPOSITION- AND
WE'VE ALLEN ADDS- IN THE
WITNESS THROUGH. OVER TIME ON
THE PHONE OKAY- I'LL GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M ALLEN APPS
THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICER FOR THE
BAY AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT ONE OF ONLY TWO AIR
DISTRICTS THAT CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENT THE CARL MOYER ABOUT
YOUR INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY THREE
PROPOSES THAT CHANGED. RIGHT
AND I SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL CARL MOYER PROGRAM IS
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM DEVELOPED
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE THAT
PROVIDES FUNDING TO EQUIPMENT
OWNERS WHO SEEK TO SCRAP AND
REPLACE EXISTING VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT WITH CLEANER
ALTERNATIVES. IN HIS
ADMINISTERED IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IN THE THIRTY
FIVE YEARDISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA CONTRARY TO THE
LEGISLATIVE FINDINGS IN EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY THREE THE PROGRAM
IS A VERY EFFECTIVE DRIVER OF
THE MEDIA AND YOUR TERM
EMISSION REDUCTION WHICH IS
REPLACED OVER SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND ENGINE SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. PROVIDING REGIONAL
AND LOCAL AIR QUALITY PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS COLLECTIVELY
READ WE'VE REDUCED EMISSIONS BY
OVER ONE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND TONS OF NITROGEN
OXIDES IN REACTIVE ORGANIC
GASES AND SEVENTY ONE HUNDRED
TONS OF DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER A KNOWN CARCINOGEN. THIS
PROGRAM IS THE GOLD STANDARD OF
STATE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THE
MORE YOUR V. I. P. PROGRAM IS A
STREAMLINED APPROACH TO THE
TRADITIONAL MORE YOUR PROGRAM
THAT IS CURRENTLY LIMITED TO
OWNERS AND OPERATORS WITH FLEET
OF TEN OR FEWER VEHICLES. THE
GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM IS TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM ANY HEAVY.
DUTY TRUCKS IN VERY SMALL
COOLEY. LARGER TRUCKS OPERATORS
THE WITH MORE THAN TEN VEHICLES
IN A FLEET ARE STILL ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE TRADITIONAL
MOYER PROGRAM WHICH INCLUDES
ANNUAL REPORTING AND TRACKING.
AS I MENTIONED OF WORLD ONE OF
ONLY TWO WHERE DISTRICTS THAT
ADMINISTER MORE YOUR V. I. P.
AND HISTORICALLY FOR US IT'S
BEEN USED IN THE BAY AREA BY
OWNER OPERATORS WITH ONLY ONE
TO TWO TRUCKS. TYPICALLY
DRAYAGE TRUCKS WITH THE
MAJORITY OF THE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS OCCURRING IN OUR
MOST BURDEN COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
WEST OAKLAND. THE CURRENT VIP
AT THE SUCCESSFUL COMMUNITY
PROGRAM GEARED TO SMALL
INDEPENDENT TRUCKERS THAT MAY
BE CHALLENGED IN PARTICIPATING
IN THE FULL CARL MOYER PROGRAM.
AB THREE SIXTY THREE INSTEAD
DIRECT CARD TO CHANGE THE
PROGRAM GUIDELINES. THE OPEN
THE PROGRAM TO FLEETS OF ALL
SIZES AND EQUIPMENT TYPES. AND
ALLOW OUT OF STATE
PARTICIPATION RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WORKING IN IN THE-
AFTERNOON WHEN MY RAPID ALLOWS
LARGE- YES- CARBERRY DISTRICTS
ANOTHER STAKEHOLDERS MEETING.
PLEADED JUST CHANGES TO THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND WE
SUGGEST THAT RATHER THAN AB
THREE SIXTY THREE- THE
STAKEHOLDER SHOULD MEET WITH
CARBON AIR DISTRICTS TO DISCUSS
FUTURE CHANGES TO THE- MORE
YOUR V. I. P. PROGRAM AND WE-
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SEEING NO WITNESSES OR
VIDEO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE CHAMBERS AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS. I
WILL NOW GO BACK TO THE PHONES-
OUR PARTY WE OPEN UP THE LINES
TO ANYONE THAT WANTS TO ANYONE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SIX THREE. AND
LEGISLATURE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE SIX THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. YEAH ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AND AT THIS
TIME WITHOUT FOR INNER Q. THE-
POSTER NUMBER TWO FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
RYAN KENNY WITH CLEAN ENERGY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
TO BE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS
ENTERING EMPLOYEE ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS. FOR
THANK YOU. NEXT NEXT IS NUMBER
THREE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
SHERRY MERYL I WORK WITH FOR
THE NGB AMERICA WHICH IS THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
NATURAL GAS VEHICLES AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. AN
EX WE HAVE NUMBER TWO FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
THIS IS JOHN CONSTANTINE N THE
OCTILLION MEMBER DELUXE FAMILY
OF COMPANIES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE. PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY.
HOWEVER WHEN YOU OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC I WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE SIX
THREE. AND NOW. OPPOSITE TO AB
SIX THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NONE IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. I
THANK VERY MUCH WILL NOT BRING
IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS. SAYING
NO QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM LIKE A
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. I THANK VERY
MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN.
FONG BY PHONE I BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I DAILY
DAILY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GIPSON. GIPSON KALRA. THREE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I NAZARIAN
WHEN. WHEN I O'DONNELL WARD
WARD I WICKS. NINE ZERO. NINE
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROAD VOTE
OPEN PERHAPS A MEMBERS. DO WE
WANT TO GO TO THE FILE. DO I GO
TO THE FILE THE TO GO TO RUN
THROUGH THE CONSENT ACT. IF. I
DON'T ON CONSENT GIPSON GIPSON
AYE O'DONNELL. DONALD ITEMS ON
CONSENT. CAN YOU. FIFTY ZERO.
OKAY FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE TEN
ZERO GIPSON. GIPSON I ELEVEN
ZERO FINAL VOTE FILE ITEM. TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR KERN
VOTE TEN FOR GIPSON. GIPSON I
FINAL VOTE. ELEVEN FOR. FILE
ITEM THREE EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE ZERO GIPSON
GIPSON I FINAL VOTE THIRTEEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM SIX EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY ONE CURRENT VOTE TWELVE
ZERO GIPSON GIPSON. NAZARIAN
O'DONNELL ALTHOUGH I OF
FOURTEEN ZERO FINAL VOTE. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE ZERO
SEVEN FIVE CURRENT VOTE TEN
THREE CUNNINGHAM. OF THE.
EIGHTY NINE ZERO SEVEN.
CUNNINGHAM NO O'DONNELL. DONALD
NIGHT FINAL VOTE. ELEVEN FOR.
FILE ITEM. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE TO WICKS. HERE. SO
FINAL VOTE TOTAL TO- FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB FORTY ONE CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TWO FRIEDMAN. HERE
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING GIPSON
GIPSON I KALRA. NIGERIAN WICKS.
EIGHT TWO. THE COURTESY TO A
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX CURRENT VOTE SIX
THREE FRIEDMAN. GIPSON HI
GIPSON I NAZARIAN WHEN NO WICKS.
CURRENT WILL. SEVEN FOUR. SEE
HERE FILE ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE SIXTY THREE CURRENT VOTE
NINE ZERO. FRIEDMAN KALRA
NAZARIAN O'DONNELL. DONALD I
WICKS KERN VOTE TEN ZERO. ALL
RIGHT THAT'S IT YEAH WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS IF THEY COULD COME DOWN
AND- KASSOVITZ. RICHARD. YEAH
YEAH. GET.
FILE ITEM SIX EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY ONE CURRENT VOTE
FOURTEEN ZERO NIGERIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE FIFTEEN ZERO FINAL
VOTE. C. OR WEAKENED- WE GO
FOURTEEN FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB
FORTY ONE CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO
THIS AREA. A PHONE NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB. FORTY ONE. KERN
VOTED EIGHT TO. NAZARIAN I
CURRENT VOTE. NINE TO. FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY SIX CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
FOR THIS AREA. NAZARIAN I KERN
VOTE. EIGHT FOUR. SIX THEN HERE
FILE ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY THREE CURRENT VOTE TEN
ZERO. NIGERIAN I LOVE IN ZERO
NO THAT'S IT WE'RE GOOD. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN. SANTIAGO AB YOU
VOTED YES ON THAT ONE. HERE
HERE HERE HERE HERE HERE. THE
LAW. YEAH YEAH. YEAH FOLLOWED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE SIXTY
THREE CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN ZERO
LEE. NOT VOTING THANK YOU THE.
THANK YOU. FOUR YES. TWO THREE
ONE OF THE- WHAT.
OKAY.
RIGHT
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB FORTY ONE
CURRENT VOTE NINE TO KALRA.
KALRA I. TEN TO. FILE ITEM.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX
CURRENT VIA KERN VOTE EIGHT
FOUR KALRA. KALRA I CURRENT
VOTE. NINE FOUR. C. FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB THREE SIX THREE
CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN ZERO KALRA.
NOT VOTING OKAY. AND THEN YOU
COULD REGRET THE. FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FORTY ONE
CURRENT VOTE TEND TO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CURRENT VOTE. ELEVEN
TO. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY SIX CURRENT VOTE
NINE TO FOUR FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I. CURRENT BOOK TEN FOUR. FILE
ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY THREE CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
ZERO FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
CURRENT BOOK TWELVE.